[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
okay so today's the the last podcast of
the year but at the same time it's going
to be very uh I I think we can use weird
strange awesome I have a feeling it's
going to be a very very good podcast
yeah it was arranged uh uh last minute
because of flight challenges yesterday
with our buddy coming in from L.A
Southwest he had some issues when I
asked Rob gave me a look I'm like yep he
had flight issues but uh we have a Sam
Sorbo which is great to have you here
thank you uh on the podcast and uh we
had your husband Kevin here on and I
want Hercules yeah Hercules call me
Hercules wow
thank you more okay I'll take it all
right so we have Sam here she's got some
strong opinions and we'll learn a little
bit about her and then we'll get into
that as well and then we also have
Destiny uh uh Stephen or should I say
Stephen AKA Destiny yeah that works
here's a with us as well he's been known
as uh some say he's the the Ben Shapiro
of the progressives very opinionated is
that what they say strong witty fast
likes debates uh he has opinions for
everything he says which is great and uh
Destiny why don't you tell everybody
about your hair today there's a special
reason for your hair today there is I
would like to say though I consider Ben
Shapiro to be the destiny of the writer
haha
well played yeah I did a charity event
like [ __ ] three years ago I think and
I told him I dyed my hair blue and I
didn't think they'd hit the goal and
they did so I finally dyed my hair like
I think a month ago in Georgia so how do
you like it
um it's a lot of work really what's
what's the charity
um I don't even remember it was like
three years ago but we were doing a
fundraiser and one of the goals was like
if you raise like so much money then I
promise I'll dye my hair blue and then
we yeah usually when you do these types
of bets or uh you know charitable type
uh fundraisers it's within a fiscal year
yeah they're hitting you back three
years later hey by the way respect but
I'm fine no you don't even remember
um well I did it the the problem is that
like now if I want to get rid of it I
think I have to shave it all off so I
might wait for the bottom part to grow
it a little bit more and hasn't yet the
black
um the bottom has brown yeah it's a
little bit but you know we'll see
because the problem with the blue is it
fades and then it turns like a swamp
color right well it hasn't done that yet
so oh okay okay so what we're trying to
do here is get rid of the swamp but yeah
so look what we want to do today our
audience likes a good banter debate
respectfully but you know going back and
forth uh if you don't mind taking a
quick a second and just kind of giving
your background Sam uh uh what I mean
obviously have your interview I have
your whole you know background here but
if you don't mind with the audience so
they know who you are and what you've
done in the past sure I uh I came out of
film I I did go to Duke uh University
which studied biomedical engineering but
um and of course Harvard is the Duke of
the north if we're going to be playing
that game
um but uh but I left school to pursue
acting
um I did modeling for many years also
and so I'm also a filmmaker
um I had three children
and I realized that the school wasn't
getting the job done
and so I pulled my kids out of school
and I started homeschooling them and I'd
love to say that I never looked back I
did I put them back in school for about
six weeks once and that was an enormous
mistake and so now I advocate for just
full sale taking your children out of
school because awesome school is not
education what we'll we'll definitely
talk about then I know you got a book on
that which we'll get to as well Justin
if you don't mind taking a moment shared
with the audience well geez I went to
the prestigious University of Nebraska
at Omaha there you go music for three
years and then dropped out because I was
working too much I do politics online
people would call me Progressive I'm
either very far left if you're a
conservative or I'm not far left enough
if you're like a super Progressive I
guess I'm like a modern kind of like
Bill Maher where there's like a lot of
progressive values that I believe in but
some people take it way too far and
that's kind of where I'm at right now
share some of them with us like
yesterday we had Kyle Kolinski here and
I'm sure you know who Kyle is we had a
good time with them
absolutely not absolutely not okay so
tell us tell us what you stand for what
are some of the things I think broadly
speaking the things that I talk about
are the importance of the establishments
that are around us the institutions that
exist why they're important why they're
worth protecting
um I try to show that you can be
critical of them without thinking that
like all of them have to be toppled and
overturned that we can for instance like
criticize things like the FDA without
saying that like coveted vaccines are
causing our hearts to explode or we
could be critical of yeah basically just
holding institutions accountable without
saying we have to topple the whole
system I think that the political
Paradigm of the country right now is
very much like populist versus
anti-populist and I'm very much like an
Institutional anti-populist kind of guy
can you also share how you came about
your philosophies today because I do
know you know there's a range of you
went through the Iran phase you went
through the Ron Paul phase you went
through the conservative phase kind of
give a little bit about the back yeah I
guess speed running it I grew up
um is Neo kind of slur for Republicans
do they not like that they do not like
that okay I well I grew up uh I grew up
a bush a bush Republican I guess
um well Nebraska to say you're you're
sort of conservative you're about
conserving the institutions without
toppling them that's kind of
conservative sure if we want to call
that conservative now but then
conservatives are conservatives because
they seem like they want to destroy
everything so fair enough
um yeah I grew up my weird My mom is
Cuban so Cubans are very conservative I
grew up in a very conservative household
both my parents were Air Force
um I also went to Catholic school so
very religious very Catholic around 16
17 15 16 I kind of became atheist had my
little Iran phase
um our little Atlas Shrugged Anthem and
then from there I was a big Ron Paul fan
in 2008. I got a discriminate around
2010 and then from there I've kind of
slowly become more left as I've earned
more money and I've seen how unfair the
world was prior to as you've earned more
money you've gone further left a lot of
times you go further right when you
start making more money leave me alone
let me do my thing capitalism
entrepreneurship why would you go
further left as you started making more
money I think the largest thing I saw
was viewing life through the lens of my
kid uh seemed really unfair to the other
children around him um you have a kid
yeah 11 years old yeah oh wow um so like
my ability to just buy a house in the
best school district send my kid to
wherever he needs to go to school make
sure that he has all the things that he
needs like these are all things that I
love him to death but he hasn't earned
any of these right you know from birth
you know he hasn't worked yet he doesn't
do his chores all the time you know but
like um the fact that I can provide so
much for him and gave him such a head
start compared to other people
um you know when I see this guy go to
you know kindergarten first grade and
they all get their own like laptops and
iPads assigned to them like Jesus and
then you've got kids and
um you've got you've got schools in
Omaha they can barely afford computers
for like their computer room uh starting
to see things through that lens and then
also comparing like the things in my
life post becoming wealthy to
pre-becoming wealthy
um like every interaction with a police
officer before becoming wealthy is like
the end of your [ __ ] life because
like a speeding ticket is setting you
back like two months if you pop a wheel
or you break a um you break a wheel you
pop a tire anybody that drives an Omaha
knows that Interstate 80 all these
potholes will like destroy your life
seeing how easy like everything became
in life after earning money is like I
don't know it just it kind of it changed
my perspective on a lot of things so
why'd you move to Florida
um originally I moved from Omaha to
California about four years ago I lived
in California for about three years I
had kind of friends there and then I've
got more friends in Miami So eventually
I moved from California to Miami to join
those friends here why save that taxes
though I mean if you really want to give
the money back it shouldn't send a
better idea to live in California or New
York where you pay more taxes um I don't
really care much about taxes there are
certain social programs that I would
want funded and if you have to raise
taxes to fund those that's fine but I
don't think there's anything uh like
intrinsically good about paying taxes or
not paying taxes it's just a matter of
whether or not the the programs that you
want are getting funded I guess so it
you don't see anything intrinsically
good whether you pay taxes or you don't
pay taxes um not not really so unpacked
though what do you mean by that
um I feel like
[Music]
sorry let me know if I'm rambling too
much but um oftentimes people get
attached to processes instead of
outcomes yeah right uh so a really good
example uh might be housing people right
we want houses for more people but
people will look at a process like we'll
say rent control and that becomes
inexorably tied to the outcome where
it's if you support rent control you
support housing people if you're opposed
to rent control you're opposed to
housing people but sometimes that
process is not like a good process so
it's hard for people to back away from
it because in their mind they're like
you have to support this thing well it's
not even getting us to our end goal and
I view taxation the same way taxation is
like a tool it's not good or bad to pay
taxes or not pay taxes it's just like a
tool that we use to fund the government
and then the real fight should be what
do we want the government to be doing
and then assuming that we've got like
these Services you know conservatives
tend to want less liberals or
left-leaning people tend to want more uh
considering the services that we've got
provided by the government we raise
enough uh money and taxes to fund those
Services that's how I do it I just
there's not like a so what do you think
we're wasting money what do you think we
should be investing more money like what
do you think taxes should go to where
are we wasting it
um where are we wasting it man I don't
know there's probably a ton of different
areas I imagine that everybody's wasted
money everywhere um I feel like
everybody always says that I'm gonna go
line by line and then when they get an
office they're like no [ __ ] that
um in terms of where we should invest
um I'm begging like preventative stuff
or like investing for the future so I
think big Investments and education I
think are important I don't know if you
like that one
um and then investments in like things
where we know we can save money so that
move to expand the IRS I thought that
was a good one because that's a way to
raise money for the federal government
um investments in um
things like providing contraception wait
but expanding the IRS as a way to raise
money for the government
um yeah my understanding is that the IRS
knows that there's a lot of money out
there but they don't have the agents to
work all the files so expanding the IRS
is one of the few ways where the
government can increase its expenditure
on some government employees but raise
more money for the government but you
did see that that was going to cost the
little guy more because it's the little
guys that they go after more
um like expanding their right right now
they're they're devoting their resources
more towards the big guys because they
know that that's that's got the the
value added right there they expand
their agency then they can go after the
little guys the the guys that get taken
out by a pothole no
um when you're a little guy your taxes
are like the last thing that you're
worried about in my personal opinion um
generally speaking well if you look at
any I mean you can look at all the
advertising for hey if you're if you're
in debt and you owe the IRS we will help
you the advertising says there are a lot
of people who need to Avail themselves
of that service sure and also H R Block
will charge you 200 to fill out like
your W-2s I mean people can advertise
for certain things I'm just saying that
um I I don't think that the IRS is like
targeting poor people now I don't think
that's true I know some people were
worried because like
um there are certain uh apps like venmo
and cash app that might have been flying
under the radar um I don't think they
issue I don't know if they issue 1080
nks like PayPal does but like maybe for
things like that but for the most part
expanding the IRS should help them go
after the money that they know is either
I don't think they're targeting uh
poorer people if you want to talk about
targeting poor people I do agree that
that's not a good thing however pretty
sure it was conservatives that pushed
for
um if you are if you get the Earned
Income Tax Credit the ITC I believe that
there is a mandatory like 10 audit on
those people as a a contingency to make
sure that they're not scamming the
government or something with their taxes
so I would agree that that's a waste of
money in terms of where the IRS is
focusing on uh just because of the that
mandatory audit rate but aside from that
I don't think expanding the IRS is them
just going after little guys because I
don't think he raised very much money
doing that if you earn 30 or 40 000 a
year
um I don't even know what the average
federal tax liability is for somebody
like that it's probably pretty low if
not it might be nothing yeah yeah below
10 for sure I suppose it depends on how
you define the little guy that's what I
was just how we Define a little guy
before I got into um streaming I did
carpet cleaning
um which sucked balls so for me little
guys like 24 30 000 a year that's that's
a little guy for me if you guys are
thinking like 80 90 100 000 years little
guys do you know what percentage of
America makes more than a hundred grand
um I want to say three percent close
what is it what do you know what it is I
don't know you know the number 20 15
yeah is it 15 15 makes more than than
six feet hold on is that 15 of earners
or 15 of households that's a good that's
a good caveat right there I think it is
earners okay at one point like what do
you need to be like the top one percent
earner and I think it's like 300K it's
like 450 or maybe say something in that
regard all right uh 15 of this country
making over 50 of workers that sounds
like a lot to me there's a lot of wealth
in this nation or it's just not a lot of
money anymore as it used to be and you
know where maybe a hundred thousand is
not a lot of money today used to be a
big deal
in the 80s and the 90s but Destiny
question for you how much of what you're
doing
is
um
you're you're toying and trolling with
people where you're just kind of like a
way of getting under people's skins to
get attention and get eyeballs and then
constantly uh changing and evolving
where you're not letting your audience
guess who you are or put you in a box
because that is a method of building a
brand for yourself how much of it is
that versus how much of it is I'm just
changing and I'm sharing what my
opinions are today
um I'm pretty authentic I I don't know
if this is true but I might have more
broadcasted content than like any other
person alive right now so like my whole
like Journey um because I started I was
one I think I was the first person to
quit their job and do streaming full
time in 2010 and I've been streaming
probably seven hours a day on average
for probably the last like 12 years
um so I mean like you can see all of my
growth I don't think I could fake a
character or be like a provocateur
um for that extended or period of time
so yeah there's I would I would say
there's a lot of like Natural Evolution
of my political beliefs over time got it
but like when you do uh I've seen you've
seen the thing where he's says like I
believe Joe Biden is doing a great job
or one of the greatest presidents yeah
that only sounds prove me wrong
Republican okay right exactly well Joe
Biden is doing a great job well yeah
well let's discuss that well you know
like I actually generally do believe
that you're authentic we've done an
interview before we've done a two-hour
the only thing I won't own all the time
is I can get a little wild on Twitter
okay that's fine okay being Wild on
Twitter has actually encouraged these
days okay but but I'm bringing that up
because I think uh I think a part of
what Tate does is trolling
and to get under people's skins and I
think that's a great job at it I think
Jake Paul does the same thing I think
Shapiro does the same thing yeah I think
a part of what we do is the same thing
so yeah provocateur I think that's a
very appropriate word award we use today
is you know you hear the word troll more
like you saw what he did to Greta
yesterday did you guys see the back and
forth yesterday with Greta did you see
what happened with him and Greta
yesterday I'm sure you saw that okay
tayden and Greta if you want to just
click on that
So Yesterday
yeah so yesterday if you want to get
close to that so Gretta says no go up a
little bit so you don't show what she
says first no no no go down just read
that part yeah so Andrew Tate says hey
uh Greta I have 32 car 33 cars my
Bugatti is a 16 uh uh eight liter quad
turbo my two Ferrari a 12 uh you know
have six and a half liter V12 this is
just to start please provide your email
address so I can send you a complete
list of my car collection and their
respective enormous emissions okay and
the picture at the bottom is the picture
of him in the Bugatti now look at what
Greta does which is actually pretty
impressive how she responds back she
says please do enlighten me email me at
small dicks getalife.com
and then he responds back and it goes
back and forth back and forth and then
he does a video and he gets like 30
million views so there's a there's a
there's a model and a Madness to this
game I just wonder if that's a part of
where you're going where you're able to
to do that versus no I'm just talking
[ __ ] having a good time learning
um I don't know if you can do that model
anymore so the the provocateur one so
here's the issue when people talk about
trolling trolling had a distinctly
uh unique definition like 15 years ago
on the internet when you troll somebody
you're acting in a way that you know is
stupid and everybody else that knows the
troll is happening knows that it's
stupid and you do it to get a rise out
of somebody right you act like an idiot
to get a rise out of somebody the
problem is today trolling just means
like
um I don't want to say harassing
somebody but like I like insulting
somebody or attacking somebody that's
like trolling or whatever but the
beliefs are oftentimes real or even if
the people themselves don't have the
belief their fan base has it
um I would say the internet has changed
substantially over the past like 20
years and that 15 20 years ago it was
really funny to talk about like finding
people killing them online you know
saying a bunch of crazy stuff because
like everybody knew it was a joke and it
was just a bunch of kids and we were old
guys or whatever on the internet it was
just like fun and funny
nowadays it's a lot different because
you've got people writing manifestos and
going to like Buffalo or you know
Christchurch or New Zealand and like
shooting up and killing people based on
[ __ ] they've read online so I the the
landscape has changed a lot such that
it's hard to go online and be like Oh
I'm just going to troll and say all
these things because there's probably a
sizable portion of your audience that's
going to end up unironically believing
those things
um is it Voltaire that said that like
any group that gets its laugh by
pretending to be idiots will eventually
find themselves in good company that
kind of thing no I tend to disagree with
the idea that trolls were just idiots I
think I think there are a couple
different kinds of trolls but there are
people out there who are genuinely
genuinely like disgruntled and upset
with what somebody was doing and so they
took issue with it and they became a
troll and they ended up trolling those
people and then your second point is you
know that there's been certainly there's
been a clamp down on what people are
allowed to do in terms of trolling other
people and Andrew Tate's a perfect
example they just said hey enough of
that and he was to me almost an
archetype archetypal troll like because
he just trolled the world like you know
I have 33 cars come at me whatever and
this is a great example of it so they
they might want to shut that down and
they've tried to shut him down I don't
how did he get back on Twitter like what
I mean obviously yeah but he's still not
back on Instagram and some of the other
platforms well also what about I mean
you're I think you're talking about like
changing the landscape political
politically or ideologically like if you
look at the success that Babylon B has
had over the last hand yeah I mean
they're trolling they're trolling doing
the same thing the onion has done for
decades this took it to a whole
different level though right but so the
thing um and right now this is like I'm
autistically quibbling over definitions
so it doesn't really matter if that's
how we use troll now it's fine but like
trolling in the past would be like um
would would be like I go to a church and
I pretend to be religious and I start
like speaking in tongues that would be
like like the Borat approach to trolling
I mean that's the greatest
but the problem is with no I shouldn't
say problem um also I'm not trying to
say anything should be banned to it I'm
trying to say we need a banner server
but when people troll today they're not
actually trolling what they're doing is
extremely indicative of the underlying
belief so like the Andrew Tate stuff and
again I understand definition change
over time so we can call it trolling but
there was nothing like there wasn't much
of a joke to when Edgar was saying like
a lot of people genuinely feel like [ __ ]
off government like I want to drive my
cars same thing the reason that borout
resonated is there a lot of people who
felt the same way that he did that's why
it resonated I mean resonance is
the way something becomes popular he
became popular because it resonated he
didn't become popular because everybody
thought this guy's an idiot and so I'm
gonna watch more of his idiocy they they
thought it was funny because it
resonated with that's what humor is well
it's almost like playing a character to
expose to the idiocy of whoever and he
does a great job of trolling typically
the right I mean he'll do it to Bernie
Sanders on the left as well did you see
that the Latin this isn't Borah but this
is Sasha Baron's cone's latest Escapade
I don't know two years ago what was it
like
saving America or United States America
what was the whole thing I don't know if
you could pull it up Sasha yeah show
time he did it it was a whole thing
something about America who is America
to be like an Israeli yeah he pretended
to be an Israeli uh Mossad uh gunfighter
and he would go and basically convince
you know NRA type members that
five-year-old should be shooting guns or
he went with uh in like a boxing ring
with like a republican uh congressman
and he convinced him to like drop his
pants and like attack people with his
anus like stuff that you're like you
can't make this up he got people to do
and obviously the greatest troll he ever
did is Pat's favorite thing when he got
OJ on and pretended
that his girlfriend didn't know who OJ
was and just was like ah you remember
like like the trolling of this man is so
over the top amazing so the weird thing
is because there's a resonance with
trolls I struggle with Sasha Baron Cohen
like personally I I struggle I struggle
a lot that's funny and some of it just
makes me really uncomfortable it just
makes me uncomfortable and I don't but
that's the point right he wants to make
you uncomfortable that's true and so but
but I'm the type of person who's like
okay I don't need that I don't need that
discomfort level in my life so like that
last thing that you're talking about
that he did I didn't watch it even
though I heard funny things about it and
some of the things sounded pretty funny
yeah like overall and it's the same
thing it's like the the who are the guys
who who played all the the pranks and
did dangerous things the The Jerk Jerky
Boys Jerky Boys it's the best thing in
the history I know and but that to me
that she's talking about jackass she's
not oh jackass guys yeah of course yeah
you're going 80s yeah I'm going in but I
think Destiny brought up a very
a really good point is that whether it's
left or right Babylon B onion Borat Jack
who gives a [ __ ] I think trolls uh
making fun of people
um just joking around I think it's I
think I think that's part of America I
think it's humorous it's healthy because
if you can't laugh at it of course then
you're the one who has the problem
here's where I was going with this
though that's all fun and games this is
what Elon Musk kind of is abiding by
free speech I don't care if you're left
right I don't care if I'd offend you I
like all good if you don't track his jet
as long as it doesn't incite violence
like you brought up School shooters and
manifestos in Buffalo and that's I think
where the constant slippery slope is
constantly trying to be identified is
like what's trolling what's satire and
what's like no we have a problem here
that we must address and that's the
problem with that line now everybody can
say some [ __ ] which is fine but where do
you draw the line on this side type of
stuff I don't even care about the like
the indirect incitement to violence that
like people call it stochastic terrorism
is when you're slowly pushing people I'm
not even necessarily worried about that
like I don't know if there should be
rules or legislation or anything I just
wish that people would be more honest
like it's never just jokes right like
the jokes are typically like they
resemble some underlying thing that
people it's funny because it's true and
comedy like um for the recent like Sasha
Baron Cohen stuff that that thing you're
talking about that was funny if you were
like left-leaning and you'd like to [ __ ]
on conservatives that's why it was funny
because you got to see the ridiculous
like positions on guns and blah blah
blah blah if you watch that with a
conservative friend some of them might
not find that funny right like Sam did
well I don't know if it's because she
didn't watch it or not I didn't watch it
all right but I'm saying like some
people some conservatives might not find
that funny they might be like oh well I
don't you know I'm not sure
um yeah I just don't get it I don't know
I mean just like how all conservatives
don't find late night TV funny anymore
SNL funny because it's like but that's
definitely because you can only watch so
many [ __ ] Trump impersonations before
you're like okay let's find something
else to laugh with yeah the whole thing
with comedy is misdirection a little bit
and if you already know where the joke
is going like if you watch Jimmy Kimmel
and he brings up Trump it's never going
to be like and then Trump won the
lottery and it was great it was like and
Trump just fell flat on his face and he
has a toupee sure it it that's the whole
thing here's how this whole thing went
into 30 minutes I asked is Destiny doing
this to troll people or get under
people's skins and then we turned it
into a big ass topic so let's go it's a
good is that a business yeah I know I
don't what I'm saying is I think it's a
good thing I think it's good that he's
doing this I think that is a business
model today I don't do that I don't I
don't I well I think a part of that I
think a part of I think a part of uh uh
whether you know it or not a part of you
is doing it whether you're aware of it
or not a part of it is considered
trolling and you know uh getting under
people's skins it is a business model uh
Trump did it okay oh yeah uh uh Conor
does it yeah Jake does it they know
white does it you know you can go to a
list of people that can do I'm not
strategic enough yeah to to figure that
out however I my my views on education
have gotten so extreme that I'm probably
trolling at this point so why don't we
get into that let's go before we move on
can I just ask you a question because
I must admit I'm sitting next to one of
the bigger best trolls I know all right
because as serious as Pat is he knows
when to to poke can I give you an
example sure like when we had our friend
Congressman Joe walsher yeah I think
that's fair to say you were trolling him
a little bit I don't know you're not
right no yeah exactly no I don't I I'm
not I'm not not I think that's it that
is a very necessary skill I agree um no
we're not knocking uh trolling I think
it is what the best marketers do to get
a message out there yeah I think I agree
with you the only thing I would say to
be careful of is um because like I do
agree that I can be provocative but
there are some people that are
provocative for the sake of being
provocative and they don't necessarily
believe what they say so that's like the
only difference so like if you say like
oh you're a bit of a troll to some
extent I would agree I can be very
aggressive very provocative but I'm
never just like hanging stuff out you
know what I don't believe you know what
what I kind of like about today's
um uh Evolution a talent goes through
when you're talking about 2010 you
started doing streaming all that stuff
the audience has grown with you for 12
years like you don't have seven hours a
day whatever etc etc so people people
are also seeing were 30 years ago we
didn't know when somebody was evolving
you just kind of saw the product boom
here's who I am like okay here's why I
mean you have to stay in the Box versus
today you don't have to stay in the Box
yeah today you can kind of maneuver a
little bit and say look now I like this
now I like this and then finally
eventually so many things you eventually
go like yeah this is pretty much My
Philosophy we're living in a sound bite
environment now like an Andrew teacher
said this right he said you know they
take little Snippets of what I said I
set it in a long-form video it was part
of an EV of an evolved train of thought
and that was like the sound bite that
was yeah okay trolling maybe or a little
bit provocative to like wake you up and
in fact I think that I think that
trolling is a necessary part of all of
this I I don't like the word trolling
because really what you're doing is
you're trying to poke holes to see if
it's actually of substance to see if
it's true so you don't think that's good
to do I think it's excellent to do I
think it must be done and the people who
want to shut down those are the people
whose arguments won't stand yeah I think
I think any time you're making fun of
powerful people that's a good thing I
think we need to we need to uh uh the
challenge is and the reverse is true
right the powerful people who want to
shut you down that's because they're
insecure yeah but but but I think you
know I think the world wants to see you
know a what becomes a problem is when
SNL only targets one sec that's when
it's kind of like so if you do both
sides I'm all in if you do one side
that's the part where some people are
like if Sasha Baron Cohen did that same
thing to both sides of the aisle I
guarantee everybody would go watch it
but when he does it only to one side
some people yeah you know what I don't
want to see it because you're not doing
the hypocrisy on the other side you know
I feel like the left has a thin skin
uh everybody's got a thin skin that's
the reality there are a lot of people
that think they don't ever thin skin as
soon as their size is getting yeah I'm
kind of with you
these days the original board did make
fun of left-leaning people there was
that whole conversation with like the
feminists and everything it's true yeah
for sure they were definitely yeah well
can I give you one of who I thought was
one of the greatest trolls ever and it's
now these as vanilla as it gets as
Stephen Colbert when Stephen Colbert did
The Colbert Show and he portrayed a
conservative right-leaning Trump guy
even in the midst of
the Iraq war in Afghanistan it's like of
course we got to get in there they've
got uh weapons of mass destruction he's
like uh you know they they didn't he's
like you can't tell me any different
like the way that he was able to troll
and this kind of goes back to my comment
about misdirection you know where
Stephen Colbert stands these days so
anytime he does a joke you know where
it's ending and I think that's sort of
the problem that left has these days is
that
we already know where you're going buddy
and that's the whole premise with comedy
and trolling and and sarcasm is that you
that's what I respect about Andrew
Schultz and what we talked about with
him Bill Burr Bill Burr as well is like
he'll go any directions
you know you know like for example you
know this whole thing you're talking
about the left or the right who can
handle it who can't take it one of the
greatest roasts of all time is Trump's
roast I don't know if you saw when they
roasted Trump and then you know what
Snoop said about Trump he says this
won't be the first time you uh uh got
rid of a black man in his house or you
kicked the I don't know if you remember
that line what he said first one and
then guess what he's sitting there he's
being trolled by everybody and guess
who's sitting right in front of trump
his daughter and his daughter's laughing
at the jokes they're saying about his
father about her Father which was kind
of great to see him in that show if you
you know any jokes a lot of times they
say he's got thin skin I mean some of
them can be credible but if you got thin
skin I don't see a lot of left sitting
there being roasted by you know people
in media space the the Republicans
didn't Trump literally ax the uh White
House correspondent no no I'm talking
about I'm talking about no no but I'm
just saying in terms of like who can
handle it levers around I totally but
the first the first the first person you
think about when you say he can't handle
it the first person everybody goes to is
who Trump because he's got you know he's
got thin skin everybody's like oh he's
got thin skin if you got thin skin the
last thing a thin skin person would do
is to follow him I'll give you a
judgment on this here you can kind of
let's have some banter on this one sure
so for example
um yesterday Kyle came on the podcast
one of my favorite podcasts of the Year
okay not because we agreed but it was
interesting to see where he was at and
we had a good discussion right here
though yeah I mean I'm sitting right
yeah yeah this will be the second most
interesting yeah you're so funny thank
you but but we had a good conversation
and by the way I'll enjoyed Antonio
Brown and Antonio Brown was full on
disrespectful when he was here he just
kind of disrespected the whole audience
us and it ended up being a very good
podcast but
tell me what plays Trump wouldn't go to
on media where they would trash him
where would he not go to would he not go
to CNN would he not go to MSNBC would he
not go to Jimmy Fallon
he went everywhere right now let me flip
this on you how many times have you seen
Obama
Clinton Hillary any of those guys Biden
go on Fox ever how many times the answer
is never except for once do they do they
do let me make my point here the point
I'm trying to make two is the following
as much as we can say you know whatever
we want to say about guys like a trump
or anybody else if you're willing to go
in the den and no they're going to trash
you no they're looking for their moment
agree or disagree man that's that's the
last thing you can say is that's a thing
a thin skin person won't even go in
there so there's a bit of an argument
for that but go ahead
um also Bernie will do the same thing I
think that's why I respect Bernie as
well I think I don't know if that has to
Trump skin or not and I think you can
make an argument for him being thin skin
and that's exactly why he ran to these
platforms to air his grievances
um but I think didn't Trump have a
pretty unique relationship with the
media like for instance so you asked me
that question like uh Trump went
everywhere which was true so I'm trying
to think okay well the Democrats then
like they don't foxes that's true but do
they do they go on media much at all
when they were in office like was Obama
making regular appearances on octc or
Fox News or he was making his rounds and
going talking to people that gave
softball questions
during was this during like campaigning
or was this like when he was in either
way when he was in office and by the way
I've watched I've watched every single
one of uh uh Obama's interviews on late
night or he would go on any of this
stuff I I liked watching him but the
challenge was when he went on any shows
it was like so what's your favorite song
and it's like what do you mean what's
your favorite song versus uh Trump would
go on is why are you hiding everything
you know so then and by the way so who
would be thin skin so here's a question
for you the perfect perfect thing to be
thinking about we'll invite guests to
the podcast okay
somebody will email us and say send us a
list of questions did you do that
yeah
[Laughter]
thanks guys
do me a favor do the best in your
ability to look your best he's like I
got sweatpants blue or gray oh we don't
care about that that's all I got but
here's the point the point the point is
the best of time the point is the
following here's the point we'll invite
somebody to the podcast and they'll say
send us a list of questions okay and
send us a list of topics
and they'll say ask me whatever you want
to ask me sure to me the person that
says send me the list of questions has
got thin skin and is worried about
getting caught versus to me the guys
like ask me anything Trump doesn't say
what questions are going to be asked me
he just says goes he knows they're gonna
ask him whatever they're going to be
asking him versus the left hey send me
the questions matter of fact send me the
debate questions to know what kind of
questions can you edit this question
this way for me Hillary so I can be a
little bit more and then writers Brazil
got called out of course supplying the
questions that is the ultimate thin skin
Community if we want to kind of go there
and by the way you know you can make
that argument but Trump trumps the one
thing about Trump he likes to go into
that he likes going I was just going to
say that I think you can be two things
at once I think Trump can be
argumentative not afraid of debate go
into the lion's den and like be ready
for a fight a brawl but he could also be
thin-skinned well meaning like you can
be both good point it and skin does not
mean does not necessarily mean afraid to
fight and I think we have to Define our
terms right so thin skin you get
insulted but that doesn't mean that
you're not going to show up and defend
yourself but there are plenty of people
who won't show up they just won't show
up because they don't have the argument
that is not Trump's problem you will
show up that's right largely because he
is thin scared when you show up and you
just say with a random [ __ ] every time I
don't know if it's as impressive but I
didn't hear not say that again well when
you show up and just say random [ __ ]
every time because it feels like that's
what Trump's Mo kind of was but um uh
got him elected him elected that is true
they're called out on all this all the
random quote random stuff you know what
you know what it is like it's kind of
like this it's kind of like uh uh the
Republican who goes to a hardcore left
school and makes it out okay when you
make it out
you've been destroyed by everybody on
the left in that school that your
arguments have to be better yeah but he
didn't have any arguments for anything
no no I I what I'm saying to you is no
for him to go to the opposing side I
think that's a your developing muscle
when you do that that's what hurt their
feelings because they loved him oh he
destroyed yeah he declared for president
I think the part about Trump that is his
challenge here's the challenge he's got
my opinion I could be wrong but I think
he wants to fight everybody and 99 of
people are now worth fighting and it's
just kind of like what'd you say what'd
you say like like you know you go to the
club with the one friend and he just
what'd you look at me for what what he's
that guy so worse
what he just tried to do today he's
trying to fight him too much 99 of the
fights at the club listen people are
going to bump into you at the club yes
if you if future what you do it's like
dude it's a tight spot people don't bump
into each other just kind of walk
through you almost have to tell them
when we make it to the bar which is only
20 yards away about nine people are
going to bump into you they're not
trying to fight you they're gonna bump
into you it's okay I think that's his
deal
power for what you just said I just say
I say this all the time I go at this
point in my life because I went to
Florida State are you talking about
steroids keg parties and fights and hot
chicks that's Florida State for you free
tip out there and I would say this
that's College that's College Florida
State you guys all out there but I would
I say this I go if I'm going to fight
somebody at this point in my life I'm
gonna know them we're gonna have a past
we're gonna have a relationship they're
gonna do something that screwed me over
when I told them not to I'm like to
Pat's point I'm not fighting the random
dude who bumped into me in the bathroom
line and I think to use that metaphor
that's what Trump is doing it's okay to
fight Nancy Pelosi it's okay to fight
Chuck Schumer sure but to fight the
Santa well no the Santas that's fine too
very single but to fight every single
comment on Twitter and defend yourself
is just like dude I think the big issue
with that too and I saw flashes of this
during the the 2016 primaries and
everybody on the left probably a lot of
people on the right were waiting for
Trump to switch up because um there were
a couple primaries that he lost where he
came on stage and he was actually really
gracious he was like Ted Cruz ran a
great campaign here you know you guys
won here and that was good and I was
like oh okay cool so he does have a bit
of life I don't remember any of those he
did it a couple times all right because
every time it happened I was like okay
if this guy wins presidency at the very
least that's not possible yeah he's
gonna be like
there's a word I'm looking for show me
something he's going to be a good
support about it and everything's gonna
be okay but uh man it wasn't and Trump
sold himself as a businessman he acts
the least like a businessman I've ever
heard in my entire [ __ ] life right if
you're a supervisor and your employees
[ __ ] up and your manager comes to you
you never blame your employees it's your
responsibility it's your shift if you're
a manager and the store owner comes to
you you never blame your supervisors
that's your store right if you're a
store manager and the CEO of the company
comes to you or if Congress goes to the
CEO you're like oh my right you own it
that's why you get bunch of goodbyes you
say it's on me exactly and Trump was the
master of passing the buck now if he
wanted to blame the Deep State on the
Democrat side even at that I don't think
he should do it because you're the
president and it's your job to work
through it and that's what you sold us
on you talked about corporate inversions
in Ireland and you talked about bringing
people together and things and you said
you were going to do that and he didn't
um but the problem is he attacked all of
his friends too right he attacked
sessions he attacked his attorney
general he attacked his heads every
nominated head he's got people in his
past cabinet he's got like every single
person like if you were on Trump's
friends list you were like two weeks
away from being on his burn list and it
was like Jesus like can you not hold a
single [ __ ] friend in any place it's
like he loves the drama it's like the
chick who loves drama and you're like I
just I just want to have a nice dinner
or but she's on her phone
what he's saying is essentially speaking
of drama the reason that Biden got
elected I'm not trying to troll you or
trigger you but the reason Biden got
elected at least we so we thought was
like can we just calm the temperatures
of the drama sense nobody was like but
it is the best guy ever he's been in
politics no zero people even the people
that voted for him it was just like a
enough with the Trump and the trolling
and that's what got him elected listen
years ago they would say there would
never be a president from New York you
know New York City because what New York
DNA is like right yo Chris Christie oh
he's too much he's too much he had one
one of those Town Hall meetings I don't
know if you remember like 15 years ago
or 12 years ago in East Jersey put this
lady in her place and he's like well
video went viral like that but that
would never work in Alabama that would
never work when Iowa and that's just not
a model so if you know George
steinburner if you know New York if you
know Gotti if you know the people that
came out of New York the athletes the
politicians the business people that's
New York it's a very normal of a New
York so anybody that lives outside of
New York is not used to that George
steinburner fired the head coach not the
head coaches Skipper what do you want to
call him do you yeah the head coach
general manager not the general manager
yeah the manager yeah he he fired and
rehired the guy three times he did it
once on National Television Vision he's
like you're fired and he's like what are
you talking about you're fired it's like
you can't fire me like this and I
brought him back and brought fired him
again it's a little bit of a New York
DNA that the rest of the world is just
not used to I will say and he tried to
bring that to politics well I mean it
obviously worked in some areas and it
didn't work in some areas it was Billy
Martin as the coach yeah
I will say this
um
what what people have to give Trump
credit for whether you like him or not a
New York billionaire goes into the deep
south in Alabama and he's like I'm just
like you guys I'm just an everyday guy
I'm a gun toting to a guy I believe like
and these guys whether you're in Madison
Wisconsin or you know Biloxi Mississippi
or Alabama or West Virginia coal mining
country you're like that's my guy honk
honk with the horn it's like that's so
nice that says more about Republicans
than it doesn't matter
I don't know if that was the brand how
he was able to Market that wasn't his
brand though he didn't come and say I'm
like you no he didn't no he says I
understand you the common man
I love the poorly educated and by the
way I know how I know how you can
succeed and uh uh do deference everyone
is poorly educated at this point
yeah because our education system so
let's talk about that let's let's talk
about this so uh uh current education
system what do you think about the
current education system that we have
that's a really broad question well you
said you like opinion so go for it give
us a strong opinion on things I don't
know anything about you want to talk
about like colleges you don't talk about
like 12. you think go go through both
you know yesterday Kyle had a lot of
strong opinions on you know we should
forgive all the college debt all that
stuff but I'm talking more the format
like our educational system K through 12
and he can go into college as well I
read a quote a long time ago uh I don't
remember who it was from but so many the
quote that I read was that if you were
to pull somebody out of the 18th century
and you were to transport them into
today the only thing they would
recognize would be the schools that like
we have a way of educating people and
we've done it for like hundreds of years
and we actually it's completely false
okay well we didn't have schools in the
1700s nobody got educated anywhere we
didn't have schools in the 1700s we
didn't have schools
the schools there were no schools in
England or whatever people weren't like
it must have been some sort of colleges
but not schools okay colleges my sorry
but not school so they wouldn't
recognize the school system
okay can we what is our terms does
college not kind of school or okay when
you say schools you mean k through 12.
we call College colleges okay well I
don't mean that but maybe for the
purpose of this conversation that we can
mean that okay college is a separate
thing from school
um I feel like there are a couple of
we're talking about like classes I feel
like there are a few basic classes that
like every student should be required to
take that we don't
um so things like a basic home at class
I think a basic psych and a basic
philosophy course I think would be
really important
um like just a couple of the things that
help us like exist in the world and like
file our taxes and be like a little bit
critical of like the things we watch
um and then I know that largely speaking
I know that we've got troubles in
schools that throwing more money at
least in some places doesn't seem to
help but I think schools are hard
because sometimes that's like the last
stop of like a whole bunch of problems
prior to that right if you've got a kid
coming from like a single parent family
who's not getting much sleep whose
household is in like a really you know
[ __ ] up area
um you know at that point how much kind
of particular like K-12 School actually
do for the child I'm not entirely sure
um uh past that if we're talking about
colleges
um I I I think colleges are pretty okay
in the United States we have our really
good schools people all around the world
come to get educated in I think that
people opt too much for out-of-state
schools you've got people talking about
I've got you know 200 000 in debt and
it's like okay cool are you a doctor and
they're like no I'm like a mechanical
engineer but I did like seven years of
like out of state you know plus tuition
and board and everything and it's like
why the [ __ ] did you do that
um but yeah I think largely speaking I
think that like the college stuff is
okay I'm not a big fan of student loan
forgiveness
um why not
uh I I okay I coming from Like A Working
Poor background before I got into
streaming I feel like the middle class
asked for a lot of tax breaks sometimes
when I look at like really working poor
people I'm like damn these people are
[ __ ] okay and you want to have your
student loan debt forgiven when you're
gonna go on to become some of the like
the top tier earners in all of society I
think if you look at the I know they're
very interesting yeah the cost of
education has grown but the average
amount of time to pay back a degree
based on getting a degree I think is
about the same as it always has been 20
years
um to pay back your debt that's the
average I think I thought it was 15 but
it might be 28 I guess maybe for you
know yeah but go-getters like you you
can do it in 15 but on average I think
it's 19 20 years maybe yeah
um but the the the people that earned
college degrees go on to become the
highest earners in society so if we're
going to Target stimulus towards any
part of like the economy I'd rather go
towards people that are like working
poor and not towards people that are
like Engineers that just want to get rid
of like a 500 600 a month like student
loan debt pay you're saying targeting
stimulus or anything like what we talk
about rather than spend the money to pay
off people's debt that that they chose
to incur themselves in order to get
ahead in this life that they're going to
be rewarded for well there are limits to
it and that's how by the way the whole
Biden ten thousand dollar you know
student loan didn't pass correct this
was something it didn't happen
I think it's in this it's stalled in the
Supreme Court I want to say I think it's
in the new one is nobody got the ten
thousand dollars or twenty thousand
dollars did they open and I know people
are putting in applications I don't know
if anybody's gotten it yet don't get me
started on these sites they're crashing
on the websites um but the the but there
were limitations I think if you made
over 150 000 a year you did not qualify
and then people with Pell Grants were
qualified for up to twenty thousand if
you were gonna do it I think it was
probably the best way to do it and it's
a maybe a good way to get young people
like they don't otherwise you even point
this out like uh I'll say this college
prep and career Readiness is a Ponzi
scheme they got your kid for 12 years
they've already convinced you and they
have they've got 12 years to convince
the kid you need to go to college
because if you don't go to college
you're screwed and so you got to go to
college and what is that that's that's
just you got to pay a lot of money to a
school somewhere so that you have a
college degree and it's they're in
nowhere in school do they say why you
have to go to college it's just so that
you can earn the money but but it's it's
not like let's make a plan for you if
you go to this school it will cost you
eighty thousand dollars total over four
years and then you have this potential
of this earning no you can go for basket
weaving and get two hundred thousand
dollars in debt or whatever and you
completely unemployable and so my point
is the whole thing is at this point it's
just a Ponzi scheme it might be based on
data that came from 50 years ago but at
this point you know we got to wake up
and smell the coffee kids don't
necessarily have to go to college and
you you went to school you graduated no
I failed okay well I had to work too
much yeah right yeah so you so you're a
Dropout wait Zuckerberg not
not everybody can do what I do though I
got no but Zuckerberg's a drop out Gates
is a drop oh no no no no no no no no no
no no no hold on hold on drop down
Harvard people like Bill Gates and
Zuckerberg quit school because they were
too busy working on projects if you're a
guy that's failing like remedial algebra
and you quit school you're not gonna
become the next kitten but bear with me
what I'm saying is you do not have to
have a college degree to succeed in life
and so setting up a child and saying you
have to have a college degree in order
to succeed is a false Paradigm it's just
false there are a lot of people who
succeed in fact most of my friends I
don't know did you did you graduate okay
most of my friends who are entrepreneurs
who are self-starters who are successful
in life did not go to college and did
not graduate or did go to college for a
short term and figured it out and didn't
graduate and so my point is it's a Ponzi
scheme I I know they're all in debt and
now they're all saying hey government
bail me I think I think you're doing a
disservice to college hear me out
um because there's parts of what you're
saying that I agree with and there's
parts of the of what you're saying that
I I just think is not not the best
portrayal only other person I've ever
met is actually to defend college on a
show yeah because there's Different
Strokes for different folks
um when you say that college is a Ponzi
scheme it it depends on the this is why
I think the decisions you're making when
you're 17 and 18 are the most important
decisions in your life like where am I
going to school you really have to do
the ROI on College because it's been
proven that a high school completely
unprepared to make those decisions
totally agree youth has wasted on the
young that's true but it's been proven
that if you look at the math that if a
high school degree you'll earn a million
dollars over your lifetime a million
two million exactly two million dollars
which you what you will earn on a
college degree okay and then as you get
a PhD or a master's you can earn
lifetime earnings on average three four
five million right now for every
Bill Gates that drops out Mark
Zuckerberg that drops out or pbd that is
to go to college there's hundreds and
thousands of people that are just
average people so that's why I totally
agree with you on this here's the
problem that that I think is lacking in
America is there's a need for technical
schools right these vocational schools
but the problem is if you're going to go
to high school right you're going to go
k through 12 and you're taking all these
classes algebra biology math this and
they say hey by the way after high
school you should go become a plumber
what 18 year old kid is gonna be like
I've been in school this whole time and
now you want me to go back to being a
plumber and what they don't understand
is some plumbers will make 100 Grand a
year and you might only make 40 Grand a
year maybe for your liberal arts degree
New York well okay but so you're making
my point for me no but the point is this
is that that no very few people are
going to go through school for 18 years
or 12 years and then be like all right
let me go be a plumber or a sewage guy
or a guard garbage man but even though
the ROI on that that is greater than
that's true sometimes a college degree
because of the whole college prep and
career Readiness Ponzi scheme that's the
only reason why is it a Ponzi scheme if
you get it exactly you get because
because it's like a pyramid scheme it's
like you pay in on the bottom and then
as as more people pay in you will get
more money on the outcome yeah but you
don't accept that for a lot of people
they don't get it
indoctrination of that you have to go to
the some out of state school and spend
50 Grand a year if you're okay with
going to community college and taking
basic classes
that's not a Ponzi scheme a Ponzi scheme
relies for you to get the money at the
top from new people coming in at the
point that's right but when you if you
go and get a degree in nuclear
engineering you're not getting money
from the school you go out in the job
market you get paid in the job market
that's not a Ponzi scheme well it is
because when the government comes in and
bails out everybody's student loans and
all of that then it's all it's all of a
piece well okay the whole feeder thing
yeah but that doesn't happen too if
School how many Ponzi schemes could you
kill immediately and like every single
person that is like graduated would
still be making money that's not a fancy
scheme but okay so my my point is that
it's a setup okay because there there
are plenty of of kids who really
shouldn't be going to college they're
much better served not going to college
and there are plenty of kids in college
who are being disserved by being taught
things that simply aren't true about
themselves and about life in general
that's a different story so for me I
think what what you guys are saying is
everybody here has a point and everybody
here is making a good counter argument
to the other person this is what I would
say to say all of it like I want doctors
to go to college like stem is I don't
know I don't I don't think you're saying
that I think stem you need to go to
school for stem I'm not going to have
somebody work on my dad's heart that's
never gone to school and hasn't gone and
done you know additional things you need
to be a heart surgeon yeah I I and I'm
not saying that nobody should go to
college right you're saying what I'm
saying is that the the rule shouldn't be
sure simply applied I think the part I
have a challenge with is the following
area the part I have a challenge with is
the fact that you know for every one
conservative Professor there's 13
liberal that's the problem for every
like for example the one thing you got
to give so much credit to the left is
they understood if you want to control
the way people think go control
universities okay yeah you got to do
that but by the way Republicans were
lazy on it that's true they have one
school which is what Hillsdale and maybe
you got a couple other Christian schools
that you got you know Bible schools that
you got what else do the Republic even
even Duke nowadays is what is on the
left yeah Duke is not the Duke of 30
years ago yeah Harvard so so with the
Republicans rather than taking the money
that they had in creating some real
universities they just said no I'm going
to go out there and just do my business
stuff that's what I'm going to be doing
I'm not going to go out you need a pen
yeah can you give give them a pen if you
don't mind yeah thank you so I think
that part is a mistake of the right you
know like right now the left is losing
their minds because Elon Musk by Twitter
why because they've been controlling
media for how long now God knows how
long that's strategically a good move on
them so Elon comes in he starts exposing
everything and like yeah Twitter files
don't even talk about it on mainstream
media they're scared shitless that's how
you compete you compete that way I I
we've lost the competition because
they've now they've they've
indoctrinated all of the teachers K-12
so our schools are gone that's a lazy
side of Republicans do you think but it
doesn't matter because it's the kids now
that are I don't disagree with you I
don't disagree with you and you think
that we we have us we have a chance to
fight for the Second Amendment the
Second Amendment is gone because all of
the kids today disagree that are going
to uh to zero tolerance schools are
learning that guns are bad
yeah full stop but but okay so then the
question for me becomes if if as a
capitalist and a and a person myself
that I'm fiscally conservative as a
capitalist I like to say what are you
doing about a path that's my Mo in my
family life what am I doing about it
okay perfect if that's what Republicans
stand for what are you doing about a
personal responsibility then damn it
Republicans take some personal
responsibility and ask yourself how many
universities have you started how many
schools have you started how much time
have you put into it why don't you take
your top 40 50 richest billionaire
Republicans and say set us you really
want to do this I'm going to give 100 of
my money away to what [ __ ] Charities
stop spending it why aren't you paying
your money to these institutions it's
just because you graduated because
they're not United and they're lazy get
together and say Here's 50 billion
dollars over the next 20 years to build
some incredible campuses and
universities to compete against the
harvards and the yields and the
berkeleys and all this other stuff how
about we go do that and they're not
doing that I totally agree with that and
I will add save the children now save
the children now do not put your
children in school public schools any
school you're saying that in college
school school that's K-12 K through 12.
right okay what can we agree that
education is at least a quest for
knowledge
sure education should be a quest for no
sure what's the first thing
fundamentally yeah what's the first
thing you learn to do in school if you
if you want to sit down and shut up
don't raise your hands raise your hand
ask a question you need permission to
ask you can't just ask questions you
need permission first you have to draw
attention to yourself This is an
embodied lesson you're embodying this
lesson of don't ask okay and we we said
that the education is a quest for
knowledge that begins with what a
question the first thing you learn in
school is don't question by the way
we're living in a whole era right now of
don't question no questions are allowed
well watch this can I ask can I ask you
a question yes ask me a question and
don't raise your hand ma'am can I may I
please well I think the the the the the
format of school which has consistently
been there for 100 plus years now was
based on the factory workers Industrial
Revolution get in line fall in line stay
in line that that whole thing but I want
to hone in on what you do you're very
your major Advocate on homeschooling so
I'm sure you can go on for days the pros
of it but my my question is what are the
pros and cons of homeschooling I have a
lot of friends that are doing
homeschooling right now Pat's kids are
in private school I went to public
school my whole life and then at the end
of high school I went to private school
I've done it all the last thing that I
ever wanted to do in my life was be home
with my parents and learn from my
parents like homeschooling was not an
option for me yeah so what are the pros
and cons that you're seeing from being a
home school so let me say this my
relationship with my teenagers is
amazing okay you want a good
relationship with your children do not
send them away from you for eight hours
a day do not do that no zero do that
yeah okay or just with my parents
you guys can't comment because your
Waters were tainted when you were sent
to school okay the school got between
you and your parents the school
presented
I was homeless for a month and I thought
man this stuck but it's not as bad to
live
I'm with him on that because you can't
say because you don't have the
experience of not having the school come
between you and your parents the thing
that when you drop your child off at
school you are tacitly telling the child
I abdicate my responsibility I cannot be
responsible the school is responsible
the school has Authority my authority is
now challenged inside my own home inside
my own home the moment that the school
disagrees with whatever you lose
that's part of life no it's not I
disagree you're wrong my teenagers have
have never rebelled your teenager and I
have to follow a different set of rules
depending on what environment they're in
if they go to a friend's house that
friend's house might have a different
set of rules that they have to play not
if they challenge my rules
if if you're let's say that I don't know
if this is the case for you but if if
your house let's say you guys wear shoes
in your house because you do that and
you don't care and if they go to another
friend's house and then their house the
rule is no shoes in the house they can't
chat I mean they could challenge that it
would respect right the rules
have the same for school you respect
what your teacher tells you my point is
the teacher sets up this this conundrum
inside the child so daddy is Authority
except that now the teacher is the
authority and daddy told me that the
teacher's The Authority so now I trust
the teacher and by the way as we know
and I don't know what private school but
we know in public schools there's a lot
of challenge to parental rights and
parental Authority and that sets up a
huge conundrum for the child that's
child abuse can you just go back to my
initial questions obviously you're going
to be an advocate of homeschooling I'm
not trying we're not trying to sway your
opinion I don't say homeschooling
anymore because school is child abuse
the whole life you've got a whole the
far right yeah directive on this but but
let's go back to question what's the
pros and cons of home education okay
yeah so what are the pros and cons give
me like maybe the top three pros and
maybe some cons if you would the
founders of the nation Geniuses right
sure Geniuses they create they they
created this this is the greatest leap
in prosperity
never went to school top G is one might
say top G's never went to school yes
what what uh well as you said there were
no hold on I just want a quick quick
fact check for the audience so if people
start looking up Benjamin Franklin
George all these people none of these
people were educated in any institution
outside the home
there were no tutors brought in outside
there were no like teachers anywhere
they didn't go to any sort of class but
that's not the question the question is
did they go to school they didn't go to
okay but were they educated by their
parents at home like a homeschooler
would do today perhaps well you're the
one making the claim
is is that true that they were educated
we didn't have schools so they didn't go
to school but go on go on with your
point fair enough we're going for pros
and cons of homeschooling I'm trying to
get this answer so my point is the
freedom model right created this
got it Benjamin Franklin do you know
what he did
he did a lot of stuff everything yeah of
course okay but what our system does is
it pigeonholes the child and it says you
need to do this or you need to do that
you need to choose you can't do both It
also says um don't try that's one of the
paradigms in school because failure is
bad okay failure is bad what's the key
to entrepreneurship try try again you
fail yeah of course you fail and you get
back up and you try again all right but
the school Paradigm is failure's bad
that that red f on a white sheet of
paper that's bad so don't try that's the
that's the subtext that's the underlying
message or one might say don't try to
don't fail okay yeah how do you get A's
if you don't cry but keep going okay
keep going okay well I'm looking for
pros and cons here so the pros the pros
are the the family relationship sure
that's a huge Pro the freedom that the
child has to pursue his innate giftings
right and so there's a there's a lot of
freedom built in there's a lot less time
spent on on quote education and let's
let's just talk about academics for a
little bit because the school focused
very much on academics so we believe
that we believe that education is
academic right I mean when you define
education how do you define education
that's a very broad word
well your your child goes to school to
what end well they I mean they go to
school to to learn things but generally
to prepare them to exist in the world as
probably a functioning unit but you one
of the criticisms that you had at school
is it doesn't prepare them because it
doesn't teach homeic it doesn't I didn't
say it didn't prepare them period It
prepares you for the future job
hopefully that you hold and it kind of
rounds you out of the person you learn
other things do you know that school
today that the jobs that the schools are
preparing children for are going to be
gone in the next 15 years that no like I
don't I think if you go to school no
that that are being create that will be
created in the next 15 years the schools
aren't preparing children that might be
true but I mean but but who do you think
is going to have how many do you how
many besides you do you two have kids
he's got four I've got zero you if you
had kids would you send them to college
or no
well that's not the question
would you would you send your kids to
college depending on what they want to
do yeah just so you know for me it's
more around stem like my kids college so
let me let me give you an idea about
what my thoughts are on this I don't
think homeschooling is for everybody I
do think more people should consider
homeschooling uh uh right now we have
about 3.7 million homeschool students in
America it's a bigger number than I
thought by the way I'm looking at them
almost doubled because of covet yeah and
I'm not surprised he thinks one event
covet also probably encouraged parents
to say you know what I I kind of don't
want to put my kids in school I don't
like what they're doing so it was a bad
reason so no problem uh I'm I'm for the
average person that doesn't want to do
home like my wife doesn't want to do
homeschooling we've talked about it she
doesn't want to do it she's like no I'd
much rather have the kids go to school
so they go to a private Christian School
and we're happy about it my concern is
the values and principles being forced
down kids throat today
when you're talking to them and that is
a to to do that too early makes me a
little bit uncomfortable didn't you just
recently say you had a conversation I
feel like I feel like you had a
conversation about LGBT with your kids
recently or something that you kind of
that's one of those two right and and
the exposure not not just to like what's
being taught in the schools but the
exposure to the culture that comes from
the other children
so all of that is like the this this
nefariousness from the culture that's
feeding in to the kids who are in school
today yeah but we used to say that that
education was the three r's
right the three R's it's academics and
and that was the big thing is like take
the Bible out that's the three R's
reading recess and arithmetic yeah
reading right right it's not even three
hours like we know that it's a lie and
yet we we sort of like laugh and move on
but it's not education is the whole
Doctrine education should be focused on
the whole child and how to to manage
that child into adulthood you're raising
the parents of your grandchildren you're
not raising children you're raising the
parents of your grandchildren so so keep
your eye on the prize what do you want
for them from their lives and the school
teaches college prep and career
Readiness that's the whole focus of the
schools is to get those kids into
college college prep and career
Readiness makes the value of the child
his earning if if there's one then I
will say is I don't trust in the public
educational system I don't if a person
can make money if the person can make
money enough money like you know how
people just sell the dream on hey go
make money so you can buy a Ferrari or
Lambo or Bill if you can go make money
to get your kids out of public school to
put them in a private school that's
teaching the values and principles that
align with you go make your money for
that that'll be better worth of your
money being spent than going and buying
a fancy car or dream house yeah I'm not
I'm not a fan of what's going on public
schools yeah so some want to do
homeschooling and some can take the
alternative and put them in a good
private school I fully agree with Pat
and and you're again I've been to public
private but I do want to get this
question answered because because no
because there's a lot of people
considering homeschooling and that's
great Ben Franklin yeah everything the
the household but are you willing are
you are you willing to at least
acknowledge that there are some cons and
what are the cons sure so well first of
all so we call it homeschooling but the
problem is that's that means we're
taking the school Paradigm and adopting
it in our homes and I think that that's
basically the Trojan Horse right we're
allowing the school Paradigm to invade
made our homes and that school Paradigm
is not a learning Paradigm it's a don't
ask don't try don't think Paradigm so
it's it's it's the anti-learning
Paradigm that's why I bristle at the
word homeschooling and that's why his
wife doesn't want a homeschool because
she doesn't like school she didn't have
a good time in school so she just
doesn't want to spend her entire day
teaching four kids well because she
believes that it takes the entire day
because we've been brainwashed by the
system to think that school takes the
entire day but the only reason it takes
the entire day is because parents were
working and they said hey give us your
children while you're working and we'll
keep them for the full day but school
doesn't take education doesn't take the
entire day so what are the things it's a
completely different Paradigm so what
are the cons the cons of homeschooling
is trying to replicate the school at
home that's a disaster and in fact the
parents who choose the the K-12 which is
like the public school curriculum they
choose to do that at home they have the
highest just recitative recidivism rate
and they put their kids back in school
because they can't do it because it's
it's a it's a setup okay you went to
school for 12 years and you were taught
you can't
he does it feels like he can't uh
I can't Vibes exactly uh how much social
interaction do your kids have with all
their peers so my son is an extreme
extrovert he's got two and a half
million followers on Tick Tock I'm
talking about in real life
so many friends it's been real life Sam
real life friends I know how much
interaction conference and I sat next to
a young guy yeah and had some nice
interactions with him he ran all the AV
stuff for the conference I go home I'm
telling my son about this conference he
goes yeah I know you were sitting next
to Josiah he's a friend of mine
that he met online no that he met in
person okay forget about your famous
Tick Tock son you have how many kids
three three I'm asking how much social
interaction they have with other kids I
a lot and where I have to ask you why
you're asking that oh okay I'll I'll can
I I'll my fear is that they're probably
I'm not saying your kids if you're doing
homeschooling and you're hanging out
with Mommy and Daddy every day my fear
is that you're not interacting with your
peers one of the things that I fear what
what do you I mean because you got to
get out there and and and be a part of
the world my fear is that this I don't
have kids but I have a nephew that that
I basically helped raise he's a 10 year
old kid he goes to a great Public School
in Miami
um that's hard to believe for him is
that he's being bullied or he's learning
how to bully but I don't operate in fear
I operate in reality he's not being
bullied if anything he's doing the
bullying you're operating yeah I can but
my fear would be that I'm home with Mom
and Dad every single day I have like a
some sort of mommy Oedipus complex going
on and I don't have any interaction with
any kids it's my age with I'm not on a
sports team I don't interact I'm sorry
but it's not complete bull no that's
even made a tick tock account yeah he
created this whole false pair because
I'll tell you that that homeschool is
being home let me tell you let me tell
you some of my best memories of school
and anyone out there is watching this it
isn't in class raising your hand it's in
between Halls recess talking to a hot
chick over there understanding social
dynamics socializing what are we doing
during recess oh those kids are smoking
cigarettes holy [ __ ] I don't want to
smoke let me go over here those are the
gangs I may not go over there I'm on a
sports team right now cool there's my
best friend hey buddy good to see you
yeah that is what school is my kids did
they get none of that at home they don't
they don't they absolutely do not get
none of that at home school you're
saying they're gonna have to see you in
between periods what do they get to see
well my kids all did Sports they all
went to piano wait wait what kind of
sport how do you mean
you actually participate with schools
you just participate with the school
sports they'll let you they just let you
send kids or the non-school sports
leagues gotcha they they by the way they
went shopping with me so they had plenty
of interaction with people real people
adults in the stores for instance they
went to events with me so they had
plenty of it my kids all grew up on film
sets so they had plenty of interaction
with people of all stripes on film sets
so so the the idea that somehow they're
just home you're you're painting me as
if I'm I'm I grew up or I you know
raised my kids in some Backwater in
Georgia and and prevented them from
seeing people and that's just a [ __ ]
what are some home schools in Georgia
right now they're very offended yeah
okay what about the kids who go to
school who can't talk to anybody because
they're extreme introverts and and the
schools actually like kill them because
they they are so burdened by all of the
interaction like you can't just paint
one picture and say wait I totally agree
with you I I there's you made a very
clear case of why you should do
homeschooling that's great but I think
it'd be unfair to acknowledge that there
are certain situations where they're not
the best approach like for instance
Destiny and myself if my mom or my dad
was trying to be my homeschool teacher I
would flunk out of school and I would
skip class if you know what I mean every
single day because they brought the
school Paradigm into the home I enjoyed
school I enjoyed interacting with others
that has helped me become a salesperson
an entrepreneur and understanding
networking social dynamics that actually
worked out well for me so what I'm
saying is like not every kid should just
go to homeschool period end of story
there's pros and cons to everything
listen if your religiously go to CCD
there are after school clubs you can
send your kids to there's plenty of
socialism uh like Christian education
for kids like if you wanted to send it
to a private school but you homeschool
them instead you send it to those things
Sunday there are lots of co-ops and
other things
maybe you're a bad relationship with
your parents is because you were
conditioned at such an early age to
spend so much time away from them when
you went to the school to be clear I
love my mom if she's watching I love it
well you sound like you couldn't be
schooled by her so and maybe that's
because the school got between you and
your mom at an early age yeah listen I I
think it is an argument that's being
made and I think more people ought to
consider homeschooling but I don't think
it's for everybody here's some
statistics to look at 3.7 homeschool
students in U.S state what the most
homeschoolers are Carolina Florida
Georgia top three reasons for
homeschooling is concerned about school
environment uh top reason homeschool
students outperform institutional school
students academically interesting the
highest home school and great is among
students with a great equivalent of six
to eight 48 of homeschooling households
have three or more children the average
cost of homeschooling is 700 to 1800 per
student per year wow took a big savings
one in three homeschooling households
has an annual income over a hundred
thousand dollars and homeschooling saves
56 billion dollars of taxpayer money
annually go little lower to show which
state has the most it was interesting to
see was number one keep going down keep
going keep going keep going you'll see
Carolina yeah Carolina's number one with
10.4 keep going right there okay 10.6 of
all the students in Carolina are
homeschooling did you know that it is
a big number I know why is that yeah
Florida's 4.6 then it's Georgia Virginia
Washington Wisconsin uh Minnesota South
Carolina Massachusetts
infectious I think when you meet
children who have been home educated
they they're they're A Cut Above they
are more adult because they haven't been
coddled the schools tend to coddle
children and infantilize them and make
them feel like they can't
um and so children who grow up in a
homeschool environment they they do
chores at home they have a
responsibility to the family that's
that's more cemented right they're more
uh Locust focused or whatever and so I
think that um that and they're more
conscientious they tend to be more
conscientious with their work because
there's there's the Paradigm between
them and the parent not a teacher that
changes every year or every semester or
what my my son in second grade had two
teachers and they just alternated days
and I was like that's not a great
Paradigm for a kid to go back and forth
between a different teacher every day
um so there's there's there's so much to
recommend it and there's so little to
recommend against it and the
socialization argument is this cropped
up this this sort of uh straw man
argument that they've built up as a way
of sort of saying hey but school is good
for this and I'm like no the idea is
school is supposed to educate the child
so we're talking education you want to
bring in socialization I'm like I don't
care because because you because every
choice is a binary choice of okay and
the reason that we know that is because
you have your priorities so if you
prioritize the education of your child
then education is first and
socialization is well I'll get that
figured out once I get education handled
okay so there is there is absolutely no
argument you can make for socialization
that would say the child should be in
school when I lose the education
argument the argument's done let's say I
fully agree with you by the way you're
making a great case I'm not being
argumentative but but no I think there
are no calls
let's go let's trolley right now I think
there are rules and I think there are
exceptions I think what you're doing is
exceptionally the exception because even
like let's take out North Carolina which
is the complete anomaly here 10 of kids
so it's I don't know what happened in
North Carolina but every other state
you're talking about two to five percent
of children so there's there's 90 to 95
of kids that are never ever gonna be
home schooled whose parents don't have
enough confidence in themselves having
gone K through 12 having graduated high
school do not have enough confidence in
themselves to even teach their children
the third phrase they were documented at
an early age with the school system it's
the only thing they know so their whole
life is a binary like my kid either goes
to school or he's a loser How could a
parent like that be in a state of mind
to even begin to homeschool their kid I
don't know if you're trolling me with
that comment right there I just go
everything you said sorry I'm just fine
what do you wholeheartedly disagree with
Sam on and you have an 11 year old so
you could speak but he but he's making a
really great case yeah but I think
they're insane cases I don't agree with
anything almost like even the numbers
right with that you're still making the
case and you're and you're being highly
effective even the numbers over here
were crazy that 600 to 1500 a year I'm
guessing that's only spent on curriculum
like on books and stuff but that does
yeah but there's something in economics
we learn called opportunity cost and
having a parent stay at home for the
entire day that's 30 40 50 000 a year in
Lost income if they were working a job
on the other hand yeah but but you would
say that parent would insist that their
child go to a private school that could
be 20 grand 30 grand I don't know you're
going to a really expensive private
school it could be that no that's what
school is called that was ours that was
our choice
I want to send my kid to the high school
that I went to which was a private high
school and I think that's 15 000 a year
right now okay um so but but I
understand costs are going to change in
different areas
um I I think the socialization argument
is a valid one I think there's a lot of
stuff that's being hidden in terms of
what you're advocating for uh in terms
of householding so for instance you keep
saying this that eight hours a day is uh
is too much what do you think is the one
what is like the ideal amount of time a
day it should take for instruction and
then two what are the things that you
want to cut out I'm curious
by the way before you answer that I
think would be great since we're on this
topic before we move on Rob are you able
to do a poll from our audience if
they're an advocate of homeschooling or
if there's I would like to get uh maybe
some numbers from the audience quality
Home Learning would you please yeah
please do not call it homeschooling do
not understand that Paradigm that
dichotomy that false dichotomy he was
asking a good question yeah you can do a
poll without having to stop him go ahead
ask the question yes yeah my two
questions would be one is what do you
want to cut from instruction because it
sounded like you were saying eight hours
is way too much you could do it in way
less yeah and then two what is the daily
amount of instruction you think you need
like how many hours a day or 30 minutes
how long do you think you need to spend
it okay so I home educated my and I
actually homeschooled so I'm culpable
here right this is an educated no I
homeschooled I schooled them okay
because I because I bought on I bought
into the whole Paradigm and I thought
school was education so for for several
years I homeschooled my children until I
figured out that the freedom model is a
much better model and the school model
is a failed Paradigm right because I
felt inadequate I went to Duke
University I speak five languages I felt
completely inadequate to educate my own
children just to refocus I want to know
how long do you think the instructions
so I spent roughly three hours at the
kitchen table with my young children
every day all three of them three hours
the rest of the day they pursued
instruction the rest of the day a few
more hours during the day they pursued
instruction but they didn't need direct
instruction from me they didn't even
need me for those three hours I just
chose to be at the kitchen table
available to them getting my work done
because I worked full-time I wrote a
book and I also did three hours of radio
every day so I was also working
and then one day a week we had uh a
let's see when they were very young
we didn't do we didn't do the co-op then
we started doing the co-op and when my
son entered seventh grade actually
before then when they were uh fourth
fifth and sixth grade we did a full day
of Co-op
so that was from uh nine o'clock in the
morning until three o'clock in the
afternoon okay and I spent the day with
them there did what do you you said how
old your three children know about do
you mind 21 18 and 17. gotcha did any of
them or are any of them going to college
no not yet do you know what so the 21
year old does tick tock he does tick
tock and he does social media for people
and he's an actor and you know what the
two younger ones want to do so my my
second seems to like engineering but
he's questioning whether college is the
way to get to The Cutting Edge of
engineering so he's exploring his
options right now so what is your metric
for success for homeschooling your
children their happiness
that can't be the answer
no no if I let my kid run around for
eight hours a day until he's 18. very
happy no but that can't be the answer
for Education should be the pursuit of
truth beauty and goodness so as long as
I've equipped them to pursue truth
beauty and goodness then I know that
they are well grown okay my so my mind
is completely business wired so I'm
thinking like kpis like Kate performance
indicators so if I educated my child
from K-12
um in my home one marker for success for
me I would think that if he performs
well on like the act or the SAT okay
he's I've done a good job educating him
or if he goes to college and he's very
successful right that's or if he maybe
gets a good job like a traditional job
now if they do non-traditional work
that's cool but I don't know how much of
a bearing that is on like how well I
educated him right so like I could
probably set my kid up to be decently
successful on YouTube Just because I am
we started doing videos together but I
don't know if that's like if that's
showing that like I educated him well or
I'm just like kind of letting him
piggyback off my career so I'm curious
in terms of like how do you mark that
you were successful or that your
children had a a positive experience
doing the Home Learning thing as
compared to a contemporary as compared
to somebody else at the same age so to
me a a marker of success is that my
child can teach himself and is not
afraid to learn so my children will
teach themselves anything that they need
to know and they're not afraid to go try
to figure out how to how to learn it but
if I ask them what it's like the other
thing is that they're they're all
entrepreneurial spirits and so they're
they understand how business works
because that I think is something that
we ought to be teaching our children
sure um how business Works in fact my
son is a lot brighter than I am with
with regards to that I think that's one
of the powerful things that you said is
to is the entrepreneurial free thinking
Spirit Well because that is not taught
no that's no but that's not but that's
not powerful though right let's say that
I so this is going to sound like your
metric is the academic metric so well
let's say let's say I'm standing in a
room with a hundred parents okay and
every single parent here what is is it
2400 is the max SAT score today I don't
even know is it 24 I can't remember I
thought it was six but they raise it
twice
every parent here is telling me that
like oh my kid got a uh 1700 on the sat
right very quickly I can kind of
ascertain like the academic capabilities
and the math skills the English skills
are really skills of these kids let's
say that you stay in a room with 100
parents and I know both of you know this
because you guys have probably hired
people and talked to people before
somebody comes up to you and they say oh
I'm an entrepreneur I don't know what
the [ __ ] that means I'm gonna need to
see some work I'm gonna need to see a
portfolio I need to see like just
because you're an entrepreneur that
might just mean that you run a channel
and you like do Drop Shipping and you
make 400 bucks a month doing that deal
with your mom right but if you tell me
like oh I graduated from duke or I
graduated from you know even like a
decent state school with an engineering
degree okay cool I I immediately have
some idea that at the very least you can
show up and get a degree in engineering
that says something right
um so but it's superficial because it's
absolutely not superficial I'm saying
you're an entrepreneurs yeah but if you
if you also sure but if you score 1600
on the SAT it doesn't mean that you can
have an original thought to me having an
original thought is more brilliant than
scoring 1600 on the SAT that's true but
I feel like the goal this happens
everybody does this there are problems
this this goes one of the first things I
said on the show um in terms of me
defending institutions I wish that we
were better at criticizing things
without throwing the whole thing out I'm
not going to sit here and tell you that
school K-12 or colleges are a perfect
institution I think there's a lot of
wasted time
um I'm very Progressive but I think that
the ideological leanings of the school
are [ __ ] insane right that 13 to 1 is
barely even a real number because you
know that one conservative is not like a
gun-toting manual I mean that's like a
liberal conservative right that's a guy
that would have voted for Clinton right
the one conservative right so there are
definitely problems with the school I
just don't like the idea like okay there
are some problems I'm gonna throw all of
it out we're going to ignore all the
pros and we're gonna get so
ideologically invested in our particular
solution that we can't even name a
single response because I still don't
know a con from the homeschooling thing
and I can think of three off the top of
my head my sister was homeschooled um
for her entire uh life I know I know
tons of cons off the top what are the
cons um one is that you have a parent
that's stuck in the household um two is
that you have to go out of your way to
find extracurricular groups to set up
for the parent in the household is not a
con to me well you're not well that's
because you guys had a lot of money for
parents where both parents need to work
that's unfortunately for a lot of people
that's not an option right right so one
is not a con to homeschooling it's it's
a barrier but it's not a con the con is
that it's a job that you don't get paid
for you're a slave to your kid which is
kind of okay it's part of like being a
apparent to some extent but a lot of
parents I reject that characterization
okay well for the people that can't
afford to have a single uh person a
parent staying in the household for
until the child is 18. go down yeah
that's one the second one is you have to
go out of your way to um to find uh
extracurricular activity yeah
stuff it could be whatever uh thankfully
my parents were religious I say
thankfully I'm an atheist now but like
they so they had an easy Community to
kind of like do enroll their kids in the
club my sister in class whatever and
then three is support can be difficult
if um at least back when they did it 15
20 years ago it's changed a lot sure
it's probably changed a lot but it could
be like if you've got questions about
like a certain curriculum or which books
are the best or whatever it could be
hard to find that support online whereas
if you've got issues with schools
there's a whole infrastructure built out
um and then four is not as big a deal
but things related to special education
requirements can be really really
complicated in the home if you're not
ready to be like a full-time caretaker
or meet like the individual needs of a
child maybe a child has a speech
impediment and you know how to train
them you'd have to take them to a speech
pathologist instead of relying uh on
school right maybe they're asking for
career guidance and you don't know the
answer your child's like oh I want to be
um I want to be a mechanical engineer
when I grow up and it's like okay well I
got my degree in right writing I have no
idea like what God it's going to be so
those are like four on the top of my
head that are like I went to I went to
high school and I had my drama class
because I really like drama and I really
wanted to be an actress and everybody at
the high school literally like everybody
at the high school said you can't be an
actress because nobody ever succeeds and
frankly the gal who taught acting pretty
girl had spent a bunch of time in New
York clearly had not succeeded because
she was teaching High School drama in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania so of course her
Paradigm was nobody succeeds because she
didn't succeed so just because your
parent doesn't know how to get you
somewhere doesn't mean that the school
does and in fact there are plenty of
people in schools that dissuade children
like I was dissuaded from pursuing
acting which is why I ended up at Duke
University and then had debt because I
was studying something that I eventually
didn't didn't do but the other thing
that I want to I just have to say we
live in a culture right now that
believes in the school model because why
we all went to school so we were all
brainwashed into the school model so
you're very deaf definition of education
is well you have to perform well on a
test that is not the true definition of
education and the idea that it's a
terrible burden to have to be enslaved
to your child I will say this we also
live in a culture that our schools have
taught us that sacrifice is the ultimate
Evil that you should never sacrifice
anything because you can have it all and
that's a lie from the pit of Hell and
the fact is that sacrifice is the
highest good and the only reason that
our culture has survived and that this
nation is Crea it has been created is
because they understood that the free
exchange the free sacrifice of self for
something greater than is the greatest
good that we can have and that's the
basis of our economy it's the basis of
capitalism it's the basis of growth and
frankly it's the basis of family so when
you have a family you learn that you
sacrifice for your family because in the
sacrifice your true value comes out and
then build your value that's great but
keep when you say sacrifice face that
implies a con that's all I was saying if
you can't afford to stay here because
the the definition that we have been
given from our schools is that sacrifice
is evil sacrifices sacrifices it's not a
con Sacrifice by definition if there's
no con involved then it's not a
sacrifice no that's wrong that would be
like me giving my wife a 500 certificate
of some [ __ ] restaurant and be like
look I sacrifice for you get the [ __ ]
off my back that's not a sacrifice that
doesn't mean anything I didn't give
anything up to do that right Sacrifice
by definition implies that you're giving
something up if you've got plenty of
money but it's not a con
uh
you we're playing exotic language games
to say that there are no cons involved
in sacrifice a Sacrifice by definition
is a pro on one side and a con on the
other then you can't call it a con you
is it do you have a sacrifice to go to
the gym you can't call it you have to
sacrifice to go to the gym is there a
con to go into the gym there's a
sacrifice to everything so you can't
call it okay I'm gonna keep asking
questions is there a con to going to the
gym
is it painful do you spend time doing it
okay there are cons to it but there are
Pros too you're healthier you can't just
call it a con it's disingenuous
you would say there are pros and cons
that's what we were saying before that
was Adam's initial question I think two
hours ago was What are the pros and what
are the cons just because something
might be on the net good they're still
going to be cons involved sure sure okay
not good sure also I think it's
important to note you you mentioned
having this really bad Drama teacher
um all of us have had bad teachers I
imagine right all of us have probably
also had hopefully at least one we've
had good teachers and Bad Teachers yes
exceptionally amazing right but we tend
to glorify the school and say but school
is net good and my my view is school is
net bad okay but the people and that's
going to school
I think that different people will say
well there was a net positive and there
was a net negative I think that's this
is the whole fundamental question I was
asking what are the pros and cons
because I don't think that they're all
Pros
of doing homeschooling I also don't
think there's all kinds of going to
actual school right but the but and and
of course my viewpoint is
net
good for schools net bad for school
what's your how old is your youngest kid
17. okay I think you guys should just
swap lives for a day and your kid should
go to homeschooling with Sam and your
kid to go to I wish
you want to take it from here try it
because it is the most amazing I'm sure
I don't understand here's what you
here's what here's what people who send
their children to school don't
understand they they fundamentally can't
understand the sacrifice that they are
making
I mean you say that but then on the
other hand too I was a lot more lukewarm
to the idea until Adam started asking
about the socialization stuff I feel
like there's a lot of socialization that
you're under counting for your children
when he asked you like what kind of
friends do my kids have and your first
answers well he's a two million follower
kind of tick tock in my opinion that's
actually one of the fundamental driving
forces in our society today that is
destroying children yeah he doesn't
believe in touch my point is you might
not believe in it but it's too much I
think you're just mad that he has more
followers on Tick Tock than you always
my accounts keep getting bad exactly bro
depressed because you want the
homeschool cause he went to school and
you hung out on the wrong let me let me
clarify that my point with that is he's
an extreme extrovert he has a ton of
friends everywhere like he goes he goes
he listens he here's the let's
transition to a different topic here's
what I will say on on just listen to you
guys going back and forth uh you know
what you think the world of a
homeschooling is you don't have full
context on it right we're totally agree
okay what she thinks of everything else
as being very evil may not be as
realistic to you and I because we're
like yeah I mean like the biggest thing
for me is the reason why I like uh
conversations like this is because I
learned through debate that's how I
learned that I learned through people
debate sometimes if it's at the house
they're only hearing from one
personality one teacher there isn't
enough debate maybe that's one thing uh
that is a high value in our family I
love debate I love exchange I love
disagreement because it's getting your
brain to work it's like a muscle work in
here if you don't have that there's no
debate so it's not getting us to learn
so we read good books right I mean yeah
we we read plenty of books in our family
and I still like to have the debates now
on the flip side of it let me tell you
what what does concern me this whole
like sex sex change stuff that they're
talking about right now is transgender
right
um hey you know what's wrong with it you
should let them do it they should let
them go through it you know what's wrong
with a kid wanting to do that and hey if
the parent agrees and proves to they
should let them do it
some of that stuff for me is the brain's
not yet been fully shaped to make tough
decisions like that in your life that
should come later on to me uh to make
some of those things introduced to kids
like hey now we got seven billion
different pronouns to go to school and I
gotta my kids gotta come and say my one
of my classmates today said they have a
pronoun they want to be called this what
is that that I don't want to have those
conversations with you I just don't and
the public school has made the mistake
of allowing that to be normal and
they're taking a hit for it by the way
states have also made a mistake
California is losing people to other
states so is New York so as other people
and a lot of people in Florida no matter
what they say about DeSantis love them
or hate them his philosophies took him
from barely winning the governorship by
thirty four thousand votes to winning by
1.5 million votes he's speaking to
parents who have similar fears to the
ones that you have so power to him you
are not alone here you know uh uh on you
talking about the issues that you're
talking about anyways let's transition
to your favorite present of all time uh
oh wait before before you move on can I
just say yes the pronoun debate is
really funny because all the pronouns
they're talking about are third person
which means they're way too concerned
with how I talk about them to somebody
else because none of the pronouns are
you or me
do you see what I'm saying you have to
be a little bit of a guy he him they
it's all third person so it's only so if
you're telling me your pronouns you're
way too concerned with what I'm saying
about you behind your back by the way
you know where I learned about third
person and pronouns and adjectives
that's cool school was a great place to
learn about that kind of you know who
could have taught you you your mom if
your mom loved you but she clearly
didn't but my mom could not teach a
class when you've got an I can't kid you
know what are you gonna do with it yeah
I don't know yeah so there's one thing
that I want to say on that well
obviously every parent is different
everybody tries to do what they can this
is just and it's hard to get data on
this it's just feelings that I have
um
when parents talk about how upset they
are that teachers are introducing
certain material into the classroom
um some actually let me back up one sec
let me use a other example so I can show
my site first okay you did you see all
the clips that came out with teachers
that were really upset about kids like
bullying other kids because of [ __ ]
they'd seen from Andrew Tate
no oh [ __ ] you didn't see that I think
it was like a month or two ago
um I feel like one of these stories went
really big and I feel like it was one of
the driving things that got Tate D
platformed was I think it was a mom or a
teacher was saying like all these kids
are harassing other kids in class now
because of [ __ ] they've seen from Andrew
Tate
um and the the first thing I thought
when I saw that the story right here
teacher claims 11 year old boys are
telling girls they are fat yeah
this story was a huge driver yeah August
16th yeah literally right when he got
canceled was one of the big drivers that
got him pushed off was people were
starting to see at shop in schools the
first thing that I thought when I saw
that was wow um that's pretty horrible
but then the second thought immediately
after was like hold on we always [ __ ]
bully people in school the only
difference is is that now we have a
microscope on everything we can see
everything that our kids are doing right
and it's like oh my God calling people
fat dude the [ __ ] we used to say in
school is gonna be abandoned [ __ ]
Twitter on everyone the meanest people
in the world are eight grade kids
um so when I see this I think like this
has probably always been going on when
parents get really upset about things
that teachers are saying to kids my my
personal feeling is is I feel like
um I feel like the goal should be your
kid gets exposed to a lot of stuff and
hopefully he's comfortable enough to
bring it up to you in a in a house
setting a home setting to say like Hey
Dad Mom I saw this at school today I got
questions about this and then you kind
of like answer the questions and you
hopefully push them in the direction
that you feel is personally correct so
if you personally don't feel like trans
people are real or if you think it's all
a bunch of [ __ ] then you know you
talk to you can say hey some people have
this belief it's like a religion or
whatever like you kind of respect these
other beliefs we personally don't
believe it I don't believe it I don't
think you should but like you you guide
them in that direction the thing that I
don't like when when parents do this
thing where they crack down really hard
on the teachers is I feel like parents
delude themselves into thinking that
their children are going to school and
they're not being exposed to a whole
bunch of [ __ ] insane [ __ ] and I I
feel like even if the teachers aren't
saying it at least when I went to school
there's always like a couple kids
bringing crazy [ __ ] to class they're
seeing wild [ __ ] today on social media
whether it's tick tock or [ __ ] kids
talking to them in Roblox or on their
switch in fortnite or whatever and I the
worry that I have for some parents is
they think that as long as teachers
aren't saying crazy things my kid is
going to school and he's not learning a
single bad thing ever and then he comes
home fair enough um I'm only I'm 34
today but I remember even my parents
like sometimes when I talk to adults I'm
not saying you guys are like us but I
talk to adults and I'm like damn like
you're only like 40. do you really
forget what it was like to be in school
that like the first time you saw porn
with some weird kid that like printed
out like boobs and showed it to you
between class or something like you
learn like the wildest Things between
between classes and I yeah I would just
I would hope that parents that are like
cracking down so much on teachers aren't
deluding themselves into thinking that
like my kid's not being exposed to any
of this and then they never talk to them
at all about it I I don't think I don't
think that's the issue I mean I remember
being exposed to porn I don't it was
probably one of the greatest days of my
life
amazing this is fantastic LA Express in
high school there's that troll Junior
High School you know uh my mom first
time she caught this stuff I used to
hide in a good place until she figured
it out but I still had a good place she
could never figure out but anyway that's
a different story my friends I I that's
an I can kid I grew up I grew up around
drugs I grew up around gangs I grew up
along all of that my parents got
divorced twice so it's not like I wasn't
around and I was the kid that parents
had stayed away from okay that kid and I
joined the army I'm a 1.8 GPA kid I'm
the 880 SAT score that's this guy so
it's not like it's uh the other way
around I want to say this I couldn't
wait to leave the place I'm like you
want me to sit here for how many hours
you're out of your freaking mind you
want me to sit here for this long no I'm
out I'm good at math I could give a [ __ ]
about writing so I scored very high on
math
and then I left no
uh I I understand like you know can you
keep your kids away from drugs I still
live in Plano and Plano back in the 90s
or 2000s had a reputation of heroin a
lot of kids died from heroin at Plano
High School it had a very bad reputation
so the first time we moved to Plano
Texas hey did you know plain was a rich
Community oh that's awesome did you know
kids died from heroin in Plano you don't
hear that in every Community it's like
well there is influence for other kids
to be exposed to heroin and kids are
dying
the part that to me is very weird when
when people make stupid things real
meaning you know
2.2 is four well it could be five it
could be this no no you don't don't
confuse my kid it's only four there's
only one answer to it right with what we
want to do you know you may not be a boy
you may have a female you may want to be
a woman and don't let your mom and dad
convince you otherwise yeah don't put
that in my 13 year old kid's head you're
confusing the [ __ ] out of them don't do
that yeah I don't need you to do that to
my kid that's the areas that I have a
problem with I don't have a problem with
you know hey Dad they said rich people
are greedy okay let's hash it out let's
talk about hey Dad they said you know
black people are this white people are
dead this person is this one of my
classmates pregnant we just had case I'm
talking to one of my in a Christian
School 13 year old good girl
I had a kid got an abortion and the
girls are talking about at a Christian
School wow this conversations they I
went to an all boy school but if you're
one of the all girls because you got
pregnant they kicked you out of this
well but but the point is like they kept
it amongst the girls okay and it hasn't
gone to the top to be able to because
this just happened I don't know what's
gonna end up happening but sure they're
being exposed to it so these kids are
kids that their parents have money so
guess what hey you want to try ecstasy
you want to try cooking I'm not worried
about that stuff there's gonna be
exposed to it none of that stuff I'm I'm
among I'm uncomfortable with
manipulation I'm uncomfortable with
making the uh uh questioning of where a
kid naturally should go to to say well
you know maybe you are this maybe you
are that that's my concern too early
later on it is what it is you know you
do that too early I have a challenge
with that once I went into the army
Destiny at 18 years old you know what I
saw by that time I'd seen everything it
wasn't like anything was new to me okay
uh but I feel like some of the schooling
right now with what they're teaching
makes me very very uncomfortable that's
the reason why I took my kids out and we
thought about homeschooling for maybe
half a second and we said no we're not
going to be doing homeschooling do you
think there is a way to teach any LGBT
stuff without it being something that
would be a contradictory to what parents
would want or always okay at what age
um probably Middle School sixth seventh
grade no no way too early no do you
think that so let me be more clear there
is a way to teach people about like gay
people or bisexual people of that age or
do you think it's totally just
impossible you know why though because
you know like this goes back to a
conversation how we got years ago two
years ago maybe a year and a half ago
where one of my friends you know he uh
straight his entire life and then one of
the things about gay converters they're
very good recruiters okay so this one we
used to go to this club in that in uh
Nashville it was a gay club great Club
okay best club in town let's go like a
Studio 54 of Nashville Tennessee sick
underground awesome music you know
energy was amazing it's where you wanted
to go if you're straight because it was
an easier game to have now everybody
would ask me hey but David I know where
you go on the weekends can you tell me
about this secret spot I said no man I
can't take you let me trust you a little
bit then I take you this one of my
friends I took him we took him to the
club and uh
this one guy who's aggressively gay and
he comes and asks the tough questions he
comes to one of my guys who's been
straight his entire life 19 years and he
says so you ever been with a man no I'm
straight he says how do you know you're
straight if you've never been with a man
he got stuck so you know what to say I'm
like dude guys are back because you're
straight he says should we get in the
car it's a 45 minute drive back from
Nashville Tennessee to Clarksville you
know what he talked about the entire
time maybe he's right how do I know
maybe I am you may what I said bro what
do you think okay I got a question do
you know what ends up happening with
this guy what
he ends up no no yes no he ends up just
to say to find out
and then he comes out he says well I
guess I'm not okay
I guess I'm not you needed to do that he
was straight his entire life but he he
thought it up not what he ended up
hooking up but is he gay now he's
straight but he had that one moment to
kind of go through it for himself
did Kevin tell you his story with uh
Versace no so he goes oh yeah yeah he be
hard for you and they're at dinner yeah
and it's just the two of them at this
point I know about the story I don't
know if you shared it on this podcast
Versace kind of groomed him a little bit
through parties and stuff and then
eventually they end up at dinner
together and they're sitting this is
your husband yes my husband back in
Johnny Versace back in his modeling days
and my husband
hot okay yeah and um Johnny puts his
hand under the table on Kevin's thigh
and Kevin says Johnny
all my life no and and he says Uh Kevin
in this life you have to and I don't
swear so F the the cow and the sheep and
the dog and the cats you have to try
everything
similar to your your gay converter
bestiality though but okay it's a bit of
a difference
don't argue but that was his language so
Kevin did Kevin hooked up with her son
he goes He Kevin goes Johnny all my life
I've been on this road and you're on
this road and Johnny goes I built a
bridge
no it was not the best night of his life
what happened exactly well it sounds
like they didn't build the bridge
nothing it was not the best night of
Johnny's life is what I meant to say
Gianni well you know they say that you
know you build a thousand bridges in
your life you know you [ __ ] one goat
you're no longer a bridge builder now
you're a goat [ __ ] that's right so it
sounds like do you think there's any
worry that so I understand your story of
your friend but like let's say that was
like one of the worst case scenarios
like he hooked up with a guy okay what
about on the other side would you get
these guys that are like 35 years old
they've got like two kids their marriage
is almost completely sexless are kind of
miserable and then they realize like
[ __ ] I'm gay and then you've got these
people that like have these whole lives
that they're about to upend because they
weren't even exposed to the idea and now
all of a sudden they finally realize
when they're like 35 36 they've already
got like a family and they're like [ __ ]
me and then their whole lives fall apart
yeah I I don't I don't know about that I
I think sometimes when a person at a
call with a guy yesterday this guy who
runs a business does seven million a
year okay
and they just had a kid 10 months ago
and he says my wife wants to have a
divorce with me so your wife wants to
have a divorce with you say yeah so how
long you guys been together we've been
together for 10 years I said 10 years
yeah married five years okay so I said
how often are you guys having sex right
now
it's like we're not
I said why not we're just not I said how
many times were you guys having sex when
you first started dating all the
freaking time I said so have you gotten
your testosterone checked down what do
you mean you're not having sex
I said one of the best things in in a
relationship you want to have your
relationship work you gotta have sex
twice a week every week and have a you
know dinner go have dinner together so
you can kind of have that conversation
together it's not healthy to not have
sex together if you have issues you need
to lose 40 pounds lose your 40 pounds
move your body get a train increase your
testosterone but it's not good for you
not to be having sex okay
when you're in that moment
we don't think that highly of yourself
as a man you're looking at anything that
will accept you because you're no longer
getting the attention you could be
confused to make a decision That's not
healthy for you hence maybe you're
talking about the 35 year old guy that
thinks he's now gay absolutely even just
your sexuality is that fluid that you
could be straight I think I think a lot
of I think a lot of people when they're
down they can be taken advantage of
listen what is the biggest mortgage what
is the biggest real estate product that
they reverse mortgage who do they rip
off the most and target people old
people why because they're what they're
they're easily
taken advantage of they're in a weak
position so to me when somebody is in a
moment like that in their marriage and
their relationship with their down
they're very easy target very easy
target or when they're a child in school
and the authority is telling themselves
but by the way let me say this to you if
he chooses to do that listen man you're
35 years old that's right do what you
got to do I can't do nothing about you
at that point at 35 years old my biggest
concern is my job is still 18. if I
raise you and protect you and challenge
you and help you become a leader by 18
after 18 you do what you want to do
it's gonna hurt me but you need to make
the decision now and kids are going to
make some decisions that's going to hurt
their parents my mother never wanted me
to join the US Army we left Iran so I
wouldn't join the Iranian Army she went
to Iran to go sell her house her sell
her father's house I call her from South
Carolina I never told her I joined the
army I called her and I said hey I just
want to call you I got 30 seconds
because I'm in boot camp someone tell
you I love you I'm in South Carolina I'm
in the I joined the army what did you do
I joined the army I gotta go because the
guy behind me is waiting got 75 people
waiting to make a call I got 30 seconds
wait wait mom I gotta go click next okay
kids are going to make some decisions
that I'm not going to be happy about the
ones that I want to protect is any form
of manipulation where kid says maybe
he's right maybe he's this maybe he's
that that's my problem you do that 35 do
what you got to do gotcha do you think
I'm just curious do you think like all
gay people are like manipulated of being
gay or do you think anybody can just
like be gay or I I lean more towards oh
oh upbringing Eileen more towards not a
father figure Eileen more towards uh
confusion I lean more towards uh
insecurities Eileen more towards
somebody gave you attention that nobody
else does so you're an ugly kid you're
not good looking you're gonna Blossom
later on in life some people that were
12 13 years old were not good looking
kids they're going to be good looking at
30 years old some were very attractive
and then they're gonna end up being fat
life is a very weird dynamic on how it
works but if you're ugly and you're not
the best looking kid and you're being
bullied and somebody from your own side
who was gay and let's just say they
themselves are coming at you and trying
to tell you how amazing you are maybe
it's a form of getting love that's
confusion to me but that doesn't mean
you're gay it just means somebody
finally has given you attention that you
are looking for and you're seeking I I
think this is a very technical Topic in
my opinion on this would probably offend
a lot of people sure and I say and I so
so because you draw the line at
manipulation of children
um which I think is healthy I think I
think we have to protect our children
from all kinds of manipulation
um and so then you have to figure out
are the T and by the way I don't I don't
criticize teachers by and large I mean
there are some bad teachers out there
but by and large I think teachers are
wonderful people who are trying to get
something done inside a failed
institution really
um there's so much manipulation that
happens in school how do you prevent
your children who are in school from
being manipulated in in whatever
whatever way well I mean first of all
you have to make it comfortable to have
the tough conversations without judging
them because they'll never bring it up
to you again if you have an environment
where your kids cannot come and talk to
you openly about issues and you snap at
them that'll be the last time they'll
ever bring that issue up to you again so
you got to make sure that happens in one
time too if you break your eyes trust
like yeah I agree I I agree with you so
I think that's on the parent I think if
the parent doesn't create and like we
have a rule out the house you tell me
the truth you're not getting control
you're not getting Papa you're not
getting nothing you just gotta tell the
truth so hey did you do that yeah I
punch him in the face okay cool all
right sounds good let's talk about it
why'd you do that okay hey did you
really take that idea did you open up
such and such as gift and without their
permission yes this was an issue that
happened two nights ago great so you got
to create an environment where they can
feel you have a creative trust with them
that they can talk to you about issues
right because if you don't have that
they're gonna go through it they're just
not gonna talk to you they're going to
talk to somebody else and I think it's a
mistake a lot of parents and leaders
make with their kids
um but yeah that's what I would say yeah
well said yeah you're communicating at
home you're mitigating for whatever's
happening yeah we watch you know we we
watch the uh movie uh uh where you know
the topic of uh lgbtq came up and my son
was a little bit confused he's nine
years old we came home and we talked
about it right and we sat down and I
told them the history of what I told
them I said here's what happened with
this here's what happened with that
these are the roles that father figures
play if a father is not really involved
the family's not involved or God is not
involved or you don't have a certain set
of values and principles we could be
confused to do stupid things we all can
be guilty of that but you're living in
an environment that this is what you
know and here's what to read this and
look at the history of this and here's
what happened with AIDS and here's how
AIDS got started and this is how many
people are killed and this and just you
kind of go through the history of it and
then let them make a decision for
themselves and I think that a lot of
parents sort of abdicate that because it
then it gets into this murky territory
and people people operate under a lot of
fear so a lot of parents back away from
those conversations they don't know how
to have those conversations that's why
that's how they convinced us that they
should be teaching sex in school as
opposed to leaving the parents to have
the sex conversations with the kids and
then the parents say okay now I don't
have to have the sex conversations with
the kids and I really commend you for
for bringing that up
um
I talked to my boys about six at five
and six years old I talked to them about
it they're not young oh absolutely oh
yeah birds and the bees because they
start like playing with themselves and
shouldn't you have to have a
conversation pretty yeah and eight
Boomer parents that would dude my
parents didn't tell me a [ __ ] thing
about mine too mine too right yeah not a
single [ __ ] no I don't think that's
healthy by the way I don't think I I
think maybe they got away with it back
then I don't I don't think you can get
away with it today at all because as you
get exposed to someone I know my mother
had huge conversations with my older
sisters and then I sort of got the brunt
of them but sort of you know second hand
in a sense yeah you know you know what
she did say that made me think about I
want to kind of get your thoughts on
this with the whole thing with kids
where you're saying well you're what
what are the three cons and she like she
wasn't given really the cons what what I
would say
homeschooling today is different than
homeschooling 30 years ago here's why
30 years ago if you're homeschooled
you're sheltered from The Real World
okay 30 years ago but if you're
homeschooled today but your kid still
has access to this you can't be
sheltered if this kid has got 2.7
million followers on Tick Tock it's
mathematically impossible to be
sheltered because 2.7 million followers
on Tick Tock that means you're also
going through the videos and you're
seeing [ __ ] that you disagree with
because we know what Tick Tock is doing
so a form of Sheltering to me without
social media today
a full-on shelter to me if you raise
your kids would be if you said no phones
no TV no movies no Netflix no nothing
that's a full-on shelter but if kids do
have Unabomber shelter yeah but if kids
do have access to this I don't think
it's the homeschooling of 30 years ago
what are your thoughts so here this is a
phenomenon you can see this most easily
like on maybe dating apps that I think
people have gotten into this mindset
that having the most Choice over
everything is the ultimate Freedom that
uh let's say I want to pick like an
ideal dating partner okay uh no
Republicans nobody from a small town
nobody that doesn't like this TV show no
no like people will ax out so many
things and they don't realize that if
they just met that person in real life
and like spent some time like chatting
with them hang out with them you'd be
really surprised at the wide gamut of
people that you could associate with and
engage with and and even have like
fulfilling friendships or relationships
with one of the things that I like about
school his school is one of the last
places where you are forced to be
together with whole group of strangers
and you have to adapt and socialize in
that situation and outside of school
it's very rare that those types of
environments will exist anymore maybe
work depending on your work environment
yeah but even work isn't all the same
age sure yeah so that so that's one of
the reasons why I like school that like
you got a bunch of kids saying a bunch
of crazy [ __ ] some of them you know you
wouldn't expect your kid to get along
with someone you'd hope you get along
with but it's one of those few areas
where you're forced to socialize with a
wide variety of different people and I
think that that's a pro to um to Child
Development and I think it's a con for
younger kids because you don't know what
your kid is being exposed to sure at
early ages so at a certain point I think
it's healthy for for uh maybe a
conversation to happen about human
sexuality
um but not at age five with a stranger
yeah potentially but I think so there's
age limits I would draw the development
of children right so it used to be that
we we used to really protect children
actually before we started protecting
children we didn't protect children they
got married at the age of seven and that
was like totally copacetic and Society
said that was okay then we said hey you
know kids really aren't of the age of
consent until they're 18 and we should
protect children and now we're entering
into a whole era where no no it's all
we're going to put it back all on the
table and children are sexual beings
from birth I mean they did studies on on
infants with sexuality and it's crazy
what they're what they've gotten away
with and those are the people who
develop the sex ed curriculum in our
schools and so now it's like totally
cool to talk to kindergartners about
sexuality and and gender non-conforming
uh things and lgbtq but you want to hear
what he has to say yeah so
um first of all I fully believe that the
age limits to sexuality are way way way
lower than a lot of parents think I
don't know again this goes to the age
thing I'll talk to some parents in like
30s or 40s that will say just dude I
remember this one but the most
outlandishly stupid [ __ ] like my 17 year
old um you know he's got another friend
and sometimes he goes over to their
house and I think they study or whatever
and sometimes it comes back at like 10
or 11 at night and it's like what do you
know what they're doing the whole time
it's like they're [ __ ] right they're
obviously [ __ ] but like people can't
even accomplish them yeah like yeah at
like 15 16 13 years old no not my child
no way and it's like like how old are
you you really forgot everything like no
shot you think they wait until they're
18 to be sexually active um or even what
you said
um I'm happy you said that because it's
it sounds weird to talk about it as
parents but like your kids get sexual
they start playing with themselves
they're [ __ ] six months old when
their boys will start reaching down
every time you change their diaper and
they try to grab their dick and [ __ ] um
and it's important to have those
conversations early I think parents put
it off way too long I've heard I
obviously my first hand experience but
I've heard horror stories that of how
many women have their first periods
without their parents ever telling them
that it's coming that's like child abuse
that's [ __ ] insane to me that your
daughter your little girl can just start
bleeding in a classroom thinking she's
[ __ ] dying and their mom was like oh
haha you've had your first oh wow um
yeah that so I feel like parents are
sometimes kind of bad at gauging the age
limits because for some reason they put
the blinders on when it comes to their
own kid and like my angel would never do
that so it's like what did you do and
then just real quick I just want to hit
the tick tock thing I think that the
tick tock Sheltering is a little bit
different and I think we have to be
really careful about this social media
is very good at showing you what you
want to see and it feeds you that
information of what you want to see and
it gets you scrolling scrolling
scrolling
um classroom environments are a bit
different because you're going to be
confronted with people that you might
not necessarily like so I think that
they're even though it doesn't seem like
it I think that a child that spends all
day on Tick Tock connected to 50 million
people can actually end up way more
shelter than a child in a classroom with
15 other people just because on Tick
Tock you're seeing a custom tailored
machine learning fed algorithm that is
giving you exactly what we see the
entire time whereas in school there
might be like a bunch of weird kids that
you do or don't get along with so yeah
but his point his point was simply that
they're less sheltered because of social
media today than they were 15 years ago
not that they're less shelters it's just
you're seeing a Fulton ideas today
I just have two questions for the panel
just so I can get some clear directive
yeah not the one with the kids at what
age do you guys think it is appropriate
we got three minutes to have that sex
conversation with your kids just very
clear
you talk you said five six years old you
said I was five six years old yeah
you know what sex birds and the bees and
the bees five six years okay all right
and then here's my question for you just
to kind of give you a binary choice
depending on the child sure it entirely
depends on the child some children don't
want to have that conversation okay we
won't have that conversation if there's
curiosity then you feed the Curiosity
and you I think I should force one out
of the conference because you're not
going to talk to them about it if you're
not going to talk about it they're
[ __ ] friends at school are going to
talk to them to the punch
binary choice for you would you think
it's more important to home teach your
kids
K through six
and then send them to school you know
middle school and high school or is it
more important for them to go to like a
public school
K through six and then homeschooled them
for middle and high school do you
understand the question I'm saying I do
what's more important if you can only
pick one I think K through six to do
what to to keep them home keep them home
until they're 12 years old and then send
them out to the real world yeah versus
then release them to the Wild and then
bring them back exactly that makes sense
okay yeah because hopefully by the age
of 12 they they understand that they
don't need school yeah they don't want
them hanging out because you want you
want your children to learn how to teach
themselves once they learn how to teach
themselves they won't take crap from
people yeah
good thank you did that help you out
yeah are you convinced now about
homeschooling yourself
it might seem like I'm giving you a hard
time I'm not I'm I'm genuinely curious
as to what are the pros and cons I think
these are conversations that everyone
should have with their wife and their
spouse and their husband and I think
this is some dude by the way did we get
results on that pole wrap
51 would not homes uh home educate and
then 49 would home educate they can
contact me at samsorbo.com and I have uh
tools for them not to go deep down this
rabbit hole but if only 10 of people Max
are sending their kids to school I think
it's a just I don't know if it's a
sample size 50 50 here so well for the
49 that is interested in homeschooling
Sam's got a book called The Playbook for
Home Learning would you mind taking 30
seconds and telling us about the book
yeah I'm training parents that they
don't need the schools and that's this
this is a this is a training manual for
parents to show them what we mean by
Home Learning your children are Auto
died acts they teach themselves and all
you need to do really is give them the
tools give them equip them so that they
can teach themselves and then show them
what they what they really uh want to
learn and figure out what their
interests are fantastic I feel like
Destiny's coming out with a book of the
importance of going to school so that'll
be yeah
if you do Home Learning right it could
probably be way better than normal
school but if you go to a really good
school I mean I'm sure it can be an
incredibly life enriching experience as
well just depends on how you engage with
it there you go okay so let's put the
link below to the Home Learning uh book
as well as Destiny's YouTube channel uh
that it can go learn more about what
Destiny's got going on as well and Sam
so guys thank you so much for coming out
it's a last show of the year I don't
know if we want to have a holding of the
hands come by yeah listen what do you
got planned for New Years we're we're
going to be partying hardcore at the
house until 12 10 when the kids go to
sleep it's so funny when you have kids
and they live with you the schedule
changes dramatically then I'm sure
you're going to be up till six in the
morning
yeah we got different plans anyways gank
Happy New Year to you have a great
weekend we'll talk to you guys next year
take care bye bye bye